Is that it never know how to start these things done.
My Rara,
Hey Joe Rogan.
What's up my brother?
I know it's thinking comedy team for us.
Let me just go Starsky and hutch kind of a thing and I rarer,
he's wacky.
I'm whack year.
What do you think I can,
we have a wife that like always wins.
I can't here my,
there's something wrong with this headphone,
Brian.
Is that it?
Check it.
Okay.
There it goes.
I found the volume.
There's something fucked with it.
Yeah.
Um,
could we have like I'm talking to wives that always win.
Yeah,
that'd be great.
Writing and talking dog.
A talking dog.
That's bold.
Like how about an alien?
Remember when they had,
what was that alf?
It was about the show.
They had a talking fucking my favorite Martian,
but he was like a normal guy from Morris eat cats or something crazy like that,
that he wanted to eat cats all the time.
Do you know the real total jerk?
It's actually really funny when you think about it.
Do you know the real guy?
The father,
the father?
And that show ended up he went when he was one that I like.
Blowed derelicts.
What?
Did you ever hear that?
No.
Nope.
I hope I'm right about this information cause I'd hate to ruin somebody's
reputation.
He used to lick the bloat like a street people.
Whoa.
I know that's a little,
that could be high risk.
Holy Shit is this is a way to start this beautiful way to start the show.
We haven't even done the commercial.
A flashlight.
I love it.
I've got to someone figure out how to do with these fleshlight commercials in a
different way and after you'd done it 200 times,
there's no way the fleshlight.
Yeah,
this is,
this is a commercial right now they're term beginning the terrific product.
Have you used one dime?
I rarer all the time.
Really?
Every day they're pretty good.
I'll tell you all that.
Better than masturbate Beth and masturbating.
I choked on my words.
That's how excited I got about it.
Better than masturbating broking and shit.
Your throat started coming choke.
I gagged.
Anyway,
go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight and her in the code name.
Rogan,
save yourself 15% off the number one sex toy from men Shizam.
We are also brought to you by onnit.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain and shroom tech sport,
which is completely unnecessary for Brian because Brian is like,
he's just not into pushing it.
You're the opposite of shroom Tech Sport,
right?
You need to like shroom tech lutes each room tech sleep.
You have sleeping pills yet.
That'd be awesome.
We'll just get take some Melatonin.
You don't have a High Libido,
Huh?
I don't even know what that means.
Do you?
Does your Dick get hard often?
Oh yeah,
yeah.
yeah,
I don't have a high libido.
He's,
he's a little bit of a pervert I believe.
Yeah.
I found out last night on the podcast that I,
you know how you have that joke about the calm in the front of your shirt?
Yes.
I also have that happen all the time and I was saying and like how one of my,
my laundry is one out of four shirts.
If I look at it,
it has the come crystals all over it,
right.
And I sit in front of Dana Dearman,
Doug Benson and Lexie Bell and all of them thought I was psycho.
They're like,
that's,
I've never heard of a guy.
Hardcore fisting everything.
Like it's Oh so still find that repulsive.
So you guys agree with me,
right?
You'll,
you'll have shirts that you look down.
You're like shit,
I was that sloppy.
Hey,
I had a time I was going to play basketball.
It was like a Saturday morning and I forgot that I had put in like a toilet
paper all over my stomach and all from jerking though.
Wait,
it was so embarrassing.
I get,
well I get up and I,
and a good Dan,
I just like maybe had something to eat real late and I'm walking out with a
friend of mine and he came to pick me up walking down to the gym and I take off
my shirt cause so fucking on it.
And there's a little toilet paper
almost to my neck,
right?
And Oh,
what the fuck.
So I go,
Geez,
never mind
the matter of friend,
oh,
that he came in the house was going to go out and have a beer with them.
When we're all living together and I hear him go,
oh,
different parts of acid.
I think he's walking around the house with his pants down,
jerking off next day.
I'm like,
bet the basketball court,
and he comes up and he goes,
didn't you hear me last night?
I go,
yeah,
I fucking hurt you.
He goes,
I broke my nose and he bent down and broke his nose.
I said,
wow,
thank God.
I thought you were joking.
Oh,
what a relief.
What a similar sound.
Oh,
it's very similar.
Oh yeah.
That broke nose feeling.
Oh fuck.
Anyway,
[inaudible] Dot com o,
n n,
I t,
makers of Alpha brain,
Trump tech sport,
which was the stuff that I was talking about,
took four of them last night.
Time are rare.
You feel shit out of that heavy bag,
son.
Get that bag.
Medicaid.
Shoot.
Your bags are a beautiful thing.
If you don't have a heavy bag,
if you can have a heavy bag and yet you're silly,
get,
get one of those things.
It's like the best stress reliever all time.
No.
Imagine what would have happened if the,
what you just went through when you were younger and less than much more
volatile.
What I just went through your head if he didn't have a family and peace with
yourself and the whole thing.
There's a lot of nonsense in this world down my work could be worth that guy.
How did he know who he was fucking with?
People are,
so we're just talking about dudes giving dudes the finger or whatever in the
car.
Like road rage all the time.
It's just so common and it's so silly.
Like people,
you know,
if someone gets in front of you like,
why are you really that upset?
You really going to give me the finger.
That's the thing.
We were like,
that hurts too.
Hey,
silly.
Like what kind of uh,
kind of a man does that?
Brian,
tell me when you're telling me you're almost eyes and shit.
Why is that shit your man like Dylan,
angry guy that takes too much supplements before going to Jujitsu.
Could think of.
He's getting ready for combat.
Yeah,
he's in war.
That's what it is.
He's in that frame of mind.
Yeah.
Anyway,
I don't like the idea of seeing myself,
by the way.
I forget what I look for.
I really do.
I forget that.
I get that.
I'm like starting to look Mongolian.
Yeah,
we talked about this last time,
a hint of venue.
It is,
I think how we described it.
I don't like saying it.
I don't believe it's real good.
Cue The music,
Brian.
Oh yeah.
And we're in the code name rogue and Blah Blah Blah.
Shroom tech sport.
Uh,
it's just stuff that we were talking about.
Alpha brain is another cognitive enhancing supplement that I didn't take before
the show.
So hopefully I won't suffer.
I'm going to take one.
I'm gonna have to pull one out in the middle of a good story.
Jody.
Yeah,
the list of questions I want you to ask me so I get they get back with me.
Zinger.
So Dom,
I understand you just got back from the zoo.
What are you should say that Joe,
you wouldn't believe all the funny things that happened to be at the zoo today.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t enter in the code name Brogan.
Save yourself 10%.
We will have the kettle bells available this week and,
uh,
all information about that soon to follow.
All right.
Hello.
Hits music.
The Joe Rogan experience.
Joe Rogan podcast my night.
Wow.
He's got a new fate every time.
The kid,
just when you think he can't just,
he can't add a different flair.
There's no more flares to add.
Just retired on Martha bottom over here.
I get so much good feedback.
Calling you a retard.
It's the,
it's the cool thing to do.
Well,
um,
Brian is
lightly playing a character on the show,
ladies and gentlemen.
It's,
it's subtle.
It goes in and out.
Even,
I don't know when it's there,
I can,
I don't record it.
Recognize
it,
but uh,
uh,
but he balances me out.
Yeah.
No,
you guys are the Yin and Yang of life.
That's what we've been trying to form a new band and that's what it was going to
be called.
We guys are getting the hang of getting Yang twins hook.
Yeah.
We would have to go to war with the Yin Yang twins.
They would kick our ass for,
for Jack in their name.
No,
we could copyright that shit cause they don't have a podcast.
We do a podcast first called the Yin Yang twins and then we,
the union since podcast,
that seems unscrupulous.
I had no idea.
This is fun.
I didn't know I did.
The show is just this fucking big.
I swear to God.
I mean it's amazing how much Chicago people coming up to me.
What God can't.
They came to the show,
he goes,
man,
you know,
I didn't really hear you before,
but you went,
you did the podcast,
you'll and Rogan.
We're so fucking funny.
I had the government go,
Holy Shit.
You know what I mean?
Like I,
I did the show.
Not like I felt like I was doing you a favor,
but you gotta show.
Of course I want to do it.
You know what I mean?
It's like,
but you didn't think that that many people are going to,
I had no fucking clue.
I'm so retarded.
You don't know what the real numbers are right now.
Probably.
It's pretty high though.
And it,
what it is though is the difference is they're with you for hours at a time and
their comedy people.
Yeah.
Did calm me.
That's a big difference.
Yeah.
Because what I like late night shows,
nobody gives a fuck.
Right.
You know what I mean?
It's hard to do.
You don't,
you feel when you do a late night show that you don't even get a chance to
really get cooking.
You're doing like five minutes or something like that or seven minutes.
Ah,
man,
I can't do it.
I just,
my my mind doesn't function like that for a set.
It's really hard to pull off and get a true feeling of what the experience of
seeing someone live it.
But you like,
like I like just to do some stuff
that's just improvisation.
Yeah,
fuck around.
And the most fun I ever had was on Craig Ferguson when he introduced me and gave
me the wrong credit.
He said that he,
you can see diamond to Denver comedy works this week.
I said,
thanks a lot.
What a cracked stab you have.
I was there last week,
but I'm so hot in a business I have to post plug things with a place will be
stormed.
Right.
And then he said,
well let's just start it over.
He came out on stage of God.
I'm starting over.
I got a spot at the laugh factory later.
I can't,
I don't have this kind of time.
But that was fun cause it was real.
You can't do that every time.
But it's tough to have enough time to fuck around is odd.
You know,
most of the times it's like,
it's so rigid.
Oh start with your first pit.
It just so fucking Corny at the desk.
And like we were just saying about the zoo.
ASB,
ASB.
This are very,
yeah,
I mean it's cool when someone has a good story,
you know,
and he gets some nick naulty character.
It's got some crazy story,
but for the most part of your,
you're accepting a contrived conversation.
Yeah.
I mean,
I saw an actress on one of the shows.
I said I couldn't watch it,
but that's some of the most boring fucking TV there is.
And Letterman said,
really?
They just want to see you.
In other words,
you're so fucking vapid.
Just sit here.
Don't even worry about talking.
You know what I mean?
I'll do the talk and just sit there because you have nothing to offer.
Has Kim Kardashian never been on Letterman?
I Dunno
what talk shows you she been on.
She has to be on everything,
right?
I don't know.
I've never seen her interviewed.
It's one of the things that I was,
I was marveling at one day.
I was like,
I don't think I know her voice.
She's been in the Lamar Odom big cock show.
I don't any,
I don't think I,
if if,
if her,
the character playing her voice was substituted with a new character.
I don't know if I would be able to pick it out.
I was like,
it's amazing that she became like super famous without me.
I mean like in my world,
like I know who she is on a regular basis,
but without me ever hearing her talk,
that's,
that's it.
That's incredible.
I might've heard like one or two of the commercials or something like that or
maybe I'm watched one,
one episode of the show.
But you know what I'm saying?
Like if,
if somebody tried to replace Your Voice,
I'll go,
that's not done.
My rarer,
I know what he sounds like.
If someone tried to do Jeff Goldbloom and this,
I know what Jeff Goldbloom sounds like,
but,
but I hear your rhythm,
letterman's voice sounds like,
I don't know what her voice sounds on Letterman.
Like you could dump this with a completely different person,
but she's is famous is like,
what's the chick's name from friends?
Jennifer Aniston.
Jennifer Aniston,
whose,
whose voice is like extremely well known.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Like Jennifer Anderson is very specific and accomplished actress you exactly
like,
it's amazing how famous she has gotten with very little words.
One,
if I want just a kid and she's getting married and was that exciting?
That could be a totally fake voice and I wouldn't know.
It can sound nothing like what she sounds like Maria Brantford could be doubling
her voice.
It's amazing how far a human being can go in the world of fame without ever
saying anything.
Well,
don't you think like,
you know,
a lot of good or Brian Alien.
I said it doesn't in this house because she's
the actresses.
Rather Brittany was here the other day.
What did you maybe even spread around?
Red Brown could nightmare is a nice kid.
She's demonically possessed.
This is actually in coder.
He's got a secret decoder ring and now it's the ciphering.
What her real voice actually is before Lucifer's powers.
Oh,
that's scary.
The freakiest shit.
Why is that demonic once a shitty rule for yourself?
Oh,
I went to Africa.
This
empowerment finds sent me and my sister and um,
my boyfriend and,
and we just went to Botswana and it was really cool.
Just see how other diamonds really help the country out there.
Wait a minute
back.
Holy Shit.
What the fuck does she just say that diamond?
Oh my God.
That was hilarious.
Holy Shit.
No idea.
Life is not real.
I'm telling you diamond empowerment,
it's a fucking Coen brothers movie.
Um,
my boyfriend and we just went to Botswana and um,
it was really cool to see how all the diamonds really help the country out
there.
I am thinking that people are going to applaud,
right,
right.
No conception of,
of what was going on there.
And so every year I like to go on a vacation out of the country.
Yes.
That's good to get out and see what's going on.
But to see,
I,
uh,
had and the believe I'm ignorant in most matters,
a different impression that the,
that the diamond industry,
uh,
maybe on a global stage was generating huge sums of money,
but locally in these countries where they were mine,
that the people were being exploited.
Did you,
did you,
that's what I assumed before I went there.
And so that's kind of why I wanted to go.
And it's completely the opposite.
These diamonds fund,
the schools and the hospitals,
they fun pretty much the entire country.
But I was a little bit just the plan and Africa because I wanted to go see some
wildlife animals and it's like this 24 hour flight.
I was so excited to see like giraffes and animals like lions and I saw a few
cubs,
but when I get home off of the 24 hour flight in Calabasas,
California,
my sister and I are driving into my mom's house and the neighbor is having a
little party with giraffes.
We flew 24 hours all the way to Africa to see giraffes,
wild dressed,
do not see a thing.
We go to Calabasas and they're having a birthday party where they hire giraffe.
We're,
we're working to get the draft.
How do you get them?
Um,
well,
I rented a monkey for my mom for a week because she was missing it.
Should that be?
Yes,
the material.
It's funny Joe.
Oh my God,
I forgot.
Good animal stuff.
Wow.
Does this,
she have a point.
I'm really stoned from watching.
Does she have any point at all?
I mean,
maybe she does.
Point was that the diamonds are good for you.
Pay for the hospitals.
That's what she's saying.
I don't know.
Maybe they do.
And you know,
you can't do that and still exploit children.
If you had to fucking dap,
Kardashians or Anacin which one?
Um,
I bet Jennifer Aniston knows how to throw it down.
Yeah,
I would imagine she knows how to throw it down.
Uh,
if you could cut off her head and switch the bodies,
which one credential,
if you can comprehend,
why would you want to cough?
Want to cover?
She's really pretty
rapid that,
uh,
like,
I mean,
I think she really cares.
She's watching this.
Whether or not I'd want to fuck her.
Jennifer Ryan is probably,
I think Jennifer has to be more fun.
Yeah,
for sure.
I think,
I dunno,
I dunno.
Was Kim Kardashian?
It does have a porno with a black dude.
That's a chick that's willing to go deep.
That's why I think Jennifer Harris,
it'd be great.
You can't fail to disappoint or,
exactly.
That's right.
You know?
Um,
whatever.
What kind of conversations would you fuck Jennifer Aniston or,
well,
how did it even get under her?
Oh,
it was like Jen fanish voice.
That's what we're telling you about.
It's fucking hard out there for a check checks trying to be famous,
you know,
if she was doing the same thing,
that if Kim Kardashian was a god though and she was doing what she's doing,
like she would be like,
uh,
especially for the marriage part.
Like she married [inaudible] 72 hours to that basketball player,
right?
Yeah.
Well,
how long was she married for?
I think it was a month or something like that,
but whatever it was,
you know,
it's like to shame they did date the do that and you do it as like a piece of,
it's a plot.
It's like this is her life.
All of a sudden become theater and they start introducing false things like
false marriages,
like hire some other high profile guy to come in and marry her on the show and
then they break up and wow.
Is that what they're doing is,
because if it is what they're doing,
it's pretty brilliant.
It's,
if,
if you think about what she's done,
I mean,
just tactically the way she sort of entered into the entertainment industry,
like a lot of people get mad.
They say she's Vapid,
she's this and that.
But what she is is she's,
she's been super successful and getting people to pay attention to her.
I mean it's,
it's fucking incredible.
it's amazing what you can pull off when you were single minded and you pursue
that and you know,
he'd do it the way she's done it and obviously you're,
you look like her.
Yeah.
You know what,
you know what it reminded me of going back when you in when this kind of point
hits you is when the Oj trial and Keto Kaylen went out and did comedy for a
while.
And for that one moment in time,
he was more famous than almost any of the comedians.
You right at the
top of the Oj trial Kato,
Kaitlyn was selling out the MGM and he was trying to do comedy.
Yeah,
he did stand up.
Did he do it before?
No.
Oh,
that's horrible.
Oh yeah.
Well Charlie Sheen.
Yeah.
Charlie Sheen.
Well,
you know who did that?
Who's got fucking balls?
I've talked about it before,
but Charlie Murphy.
Charlie Murphy.
Oh,
I know.
I didn't have a lot going on like as far as his career.
And then got on the Chappelle show and he was in his forties and then started
doing standup and he was famous.
And not only is he famous,
he was famous of white,
was the brother of one of the greatest standups ever.
So he's got Charlie Murphy,
his brothers,
Eddie Murphy.
They look alike and you know,
I mean he's,
he's going out there literally,
he's done comedy for like a couple of months and he had a close headline that's
unbelievable.
He's got balls,
that guy has fucking balls.
We did a month maximum tour on the road together.
And uh,
Charlie Murphy,
man,
he,
he's got fucking balls.
That guy,
we would alternate headline and he don't even do the common follow you.
He did.
He did a couple times.
What did he do well,
yeah,
my people,
first of all,
he's a good storyteller and,
and people love him.
And if he's in his right groove,
he,
it,
he's just got to be comfortable,
you know,
when Charlie's comfortable and he's comfortable in.
So he's got like a couple of different gears,
you know,
and when he's comfortable and he's telling a story,
there are very few people in the world is entertaining.
Is that guy,
he has this realistic,
sort of like a aggressive,
kind of like real brutal honesty,
you know,
but with a cool voice,
he,
he can tell a fuck out of a story.
Well,
you know,
brothers of famous people,
I'll take Tony Rock 20 rocks.
Hilarious.
He's good.
He's very funny.
That guy gets slept on.
You know,
I,
I had seen him a couple of years ago like way back at the laugh factory and he
was really funny then he was like promising,
you know?
No,
he's really good.
And then I saw him at the Improv like recently and I came up to him after his
set.
I was like,
dude,
you got way better.
Like that was like really fun to watch.
It's fun to watch a guy that you haven't seen for years and then you see them
and you're like,
Tam,
you've been working.
And He,
and he's like,
thanks man.
I'm going to be like him in the gym.
I'm in the gym.
You know,
he's,
he's got the right attitude about it.
He's fucking good in the gym.
It isn't,
it isn't the sounds.
What would it for us?
It's the gym.
You got to get on stage.
I mean,
look at Bill Burr.
I've seen him take strides and he's so fucking perfect example.
Bill Burr was always really funny.
But now it's like he's just a,
he's super prolific too.
Now he's just nailing it,
you know?
He's just like,
he's constantly putting out new stuff and he'd go to see him.
It's,
you know,
it's fun.
It's like,
you know,
I agree with them.
I don't agree with them.
I'm still laughing.
He says something completely ridiculous and over aggressive of still living it.
It's fucking great.
It's just,
it's,
he's a,
he's one of the last of the Boston comics,
you know,
that like,
uh,
intelligent but like still manly of progressive sort of comedians.
There was a lot of guys like Boston,
Lenny Clarke and that whole group.
That was one of the things that Dan Cook and I were talking about once about
growing up and doing stand up together and Boston was that those guys were men.
They were fucking like Lenny call.
Yes,
we're tough guys.
They were kind of Indians.
They weren't like nebbishy problems with their mother kind of animals letting
carc was a fucking savage.
Oh,
he was met Lenny right after you guys.
Did he do you need to do the Hbo Comedy?
Rodney Dangerfield?
Yeah,
I got a chance to open.
He was the second guy ever got paid to open four.
Forget about the first guy and pretend it was,
he was the first for a while.
First time ever got paid.
I open up for Lindy Clark,
cause that sounds good,
but it's really the second time,
first time was a guy named Warren Mcdonald's.
Actually a very funny guy too.
But um,
but I,
uh,
I worked with him right after he got done,
just got done doing the Rodney special.
Oh my God.
He was in,
he's a fucking animal.
Such bowls.
Oh,
he was an animal.
We were up in Seattle to see the NCAAS and that these guys,
they were fucking drinking all day.
I can't,
I mean don and all them and uh,
we're at a party and the CBS guy comes up to me and he says,
I'm a big fan of yours.
And they didn't have a ticket.
Lenny's at like Jackie Gleason bigger than he goes,
hey,
if you are such a big fucking thing,
get him a ticket to the game.
And the guy goes,
oh,
okay.
You know sheepishly like what's he going to do?
What is that movie then I think is France Salameda did that movie on Oh yeah.
Boston comedy.
Yeah.
How do you spell France?
I don't know.
Are Fr.
See?
Yeah.
Oh,
when standups France,
Alameda,
when standup stood out,
which is a great documentary on standup comedy and a all about the one town
about Boston and what it was like,
you know,
back then and it's a,
it's a really accurate depiction cause there's a lot of old video,
like old video of Lenny Clarke and those guys and,
and Jimmy tingle and then talking about the,
the Ding Ho like the Chinese restaurant was like the first place,
man.
I'm,
I was like right after that way.
If those guys were like,
these guys were the big established headliners right when I was becoming an old,
they were good to me too.
Cause they could bury people if they want it to.
Nick's,
Nick's was tough.
Well you know,
for the,
the people that don't know,
dom was one of the only guys that ever paid to see do comedy before or after.
I was a comedian.
There was only like a few guys.
Once I became a comedian,
like once I had done like open Mike Nights,
but,
uh,
I,
I went to see you remember how much it costs to say me.
I wish I did.
I went to see a day.
I want to see you a couple of times.
I went to see you,
uh,
before I ever did standup.
I'm pretty sure it was either before right before or right when I was doing it.
But,
uh,
I went to cu and,
you didn't make the flight something and Dennis
leary was in your place.
It was the first time I ever saw Dennis leary.
He fucking destroyed it.
Then I remember it was good to back then he was on fire.
He was my favorite comedian for six months until some,
you know,
I thought I saw bill Hicks and I was like,
what the fuck is going on here?
See,
I didn't,
I didn't see as much as other people did with the parallels.
And [inaudible] was a friend of mine,
but yeah,
Bill had a funny joke about it.
Oh,
he,
uh,
he actually had an event,
he went back in time and did the jokes before stolen,
then went back in time and did them before an added punch lines.
I don't know,
I think I butchered the quote,
but you know,
when they asked him like,
you know,
who stole it from who
we know what my nightmare was about the HBO thing bed,
Rodney Dangerfield was,
it was like,
I'd rather not get a compliment in the comp when I would get,
I'd have somebody come up mega man,
you're my favorite on a show beat you and that guy dice don't fucking compliment
me up to be
because you,
I've always had
problem with dice and now you and dice.
I've actually gotten into it.
But,
um,
when I was a kid,
man,
I was a fucking huge fan of dice.
And if there's anything like his comedy,
it doesn't bother me.
I like it.
Oh,
that's coming.
Doesn't bother me.
I just don't like him.
You don't like him?
Yeah.
I never have a bad problem with him.
I've never had any issues with him.
I can't be a 50,
60 year old.
Uh,
funds.
See,
I look at him,
I think he's a character.
You look at them and it's like he's some guy who disrespected you or something.
Something happened.
Right.
There's only three comedians.
I,
Hey,
let me get one.
Billy Crystal.
Oh,
considering the comedian,
what does that about?
There was a elite,
crystal was such an asshole to me.
I was really,
I was,
you know,
and he's always been really nice to me,
but he was with Deniro and I was hosting this thing for comedy central and we're
doing a review review of that shit movie,
analyze that.
Remember the first one was good,
analyze this.
It was the neuro moves and in a second one wasn't good.
Yeah.
He got rolled the Sunday's buddying up with Deniro and he like,
he starts like act and condescending towards me,
so I fucked with him right away.
I go,
Bill,
you hosting the Academy Awards here?
He goes,
I don't know why.
I said,
can you mention me to the people,
the academy?
He goes,
for what?
I go,
I don't know,
some kind of award.
You figure it out.
Then he realized,
he realized I had duped them.
You figure it out.
Yeah,
we,
he lost his sense of humor.
Right.
Too Cool.
But I mean,
you know,
he was always a right to be in that situation.
He lost his sense.
Oh yeah.
Well he was trying to act like him and didn't know where these dear friends and
thinking,
this is Robert Deniro sitting next to you.
Come on Billy and Billy Crystal Eagle.
People love to be friends with someone like to narrow.
You could put that shit on your resume.
And I'm going over Bobby [inaudible] house for Barbecue this weekend.
I did a reading with him.
Rarely do I get impressed.
You imagine someone saying that to you and wearing like a running track suit and
lawyer.
Fuck that noise was like fake Italian immigrants.
Immigrants to California from the east coast.
Fake Italian dudes.
We're always connected.
You know those guys were always trying to break into acting since this fake
tough guy dudes.
Right,
right.
Oh,
go to Bobby D's house.
Oh God.
That Bobby T.
K.
U.
Who else?
Who else is it real Sean Connery.
And if you could say you're friends with Sean Connery.
I'm going fly fishing with Sean Connery actually.
Well that's people who have to drop.
Even like countries.
Yeah.
I got these other nice shoes you've got to in France.
You're like that makes it a fucking big deal.
That's all he got them in France.
Would you,
would you be friends with uh,
what's his face?
The guy from Paul fixing shit.
That's a,
I'm a guy.
Just had a brain fart.
John Travolta.
Cause I think you fuck you.
I think if your friends,
that's what happens.
He fucks you.
Somebody's friend.
I heard it on some radio station with a pal.
What's he to cut?
It was in Greece that recently died from a drug overdose.
So that was at Contiki or not?
Cause it can negate that.
Recently died of a drug over the other main guy in Greece that that was in
celebrity rehab.
Was he the guy that was in a taxi?
Yeah.
Is that the guy?
Cause I think you're talking about Jeff something or another just recently died.
I don't know.
I don't know that guy's name.
I'll look it up.
And I had heard that,
that,
see,
I've only really watched celebrity rehab once and uh,
I get depressed.
I don't,
I don't like watching people that are fallen apart.
I don't like taking in that Vibe,
you know?
I know.
I mean occasionally I like to know it's Jeff Conway.
Jeff Conway is not the guy.
Yeah,
he,
he said that,
that he actually spent a night once at his house and supposedly this is what I
heard and radius ratio that he went over there to spend the night at his house
and he crashed and he woke up and,
and he was fondling him like,
like
Travolta was fondling them.
Oh.
Might hate that.
Don't you hate when you wake up and we in front of his playing with your balls,
you wake up in the dude from pulp fiction is sucker going and then,
and then Michael,
you suck my Dick.
Will you leave me alone?
Mike Wallace,
I heard that Mike Wallace from Nash,
whatever the inquirer is or whatever he works for that released all this shit.
Said they asked him,
you know,
like,
is this shit fake?
Or You guys just trying,
you know,
are these people really telling the truth?
And they're like,
do we give him lie detector tests?
We fucking like go and check.
Like if they say any detail like going to like hotels or something like that.
They,
they get it.
This was on the Howard stern show that,
that he said this and stuff like that,
that all these people are all telling the truth like all of them.
So all these messsage are telling the truth.
He has that crazy.
Well,
who knows?
We don't know.
We don't have an official stance on this Joe Rogan experience podcast.
Brian Ryan.
I'm just regurgitating what,
what I've been hearing on happened to know,
but I'm not talking
dogs off this.
You know what I'll be talking.
Tell us about the time that you worked as a suse
Hollywood.
Get on,
I'll be talking June 30th at the Tropicana in Atlantic city.
That's what I'll be calling those big manly hands that you have.
I bet you would.
You would give a good massage.
I hedge.
You're very soft.
They could take it toughen up quickly.
You wouldn't be a good,
good show.
Is Dom and Joey Diaz dressed up as women like bosom buddies?
I never thought I'd say this,
but I'd be the hot one
with a golden girls.
Maybe thrown another person.
Oh,
I like seeing people like Joe Cause it makes me feel not as fast.
Not Dead set.
Yeah.
I do a joke about like how chaotic my life is when I'm hanging around with Joey
Diaz.
I'm like,
I'm fine.
I just like a balanced calendar.
A leveler.
He's your canary in the coal mine.
Canary in the coal mine.
I love Joey and I know what he's thinking.
Oh man,
that look on his face.
Joey Diaz.
Could we just read the newspaper and have you crying?
Laughing.
Yeah,
just point out anything.
I never met a dude who's,
who makes me laugh like that guy does on a consistent basis.
He gets fucking crazy.
You'll get crazy about ketchup,
but he's the same fucking catch up.
Joe Rogan back in Jersey.
We got to fucking catch up.
It was real ketchup.
This is some watery bullshit.
It doesn't taste like get the fucking angry.
No,
Heinz is actually pretty good enough.
Fuck Joey just got off the road with him.
Right and and one of the hotels we stayed at,
I had a business there was like,
come on,
you got to go to the business center with me and just watching him sit here
checking his thing,
my jiggers,
they click on that picture,
like he's just sitting there like with his glasses on doing the computer system.
I worked in
and prompt and the whole day hung up the club so it could use the phone really
to make local calls.
He can fucking steal from the room,
but she chose to do it from the club.
He used to.
He used to,
he's Cubano phone for the longest time.
Joey just had a pager when everybody else had itself.
Hey Joe,
he still had a pager.
Yeah,
he would just,
you would never be able to find them too.
Now he's embraced it,
man.
He has number one fucking CD on iTunes comedy praise.
He's gone completely digital.
Yeah.
We got Joey on Twitter and then Joey started really getting into it for awhile.
Like,
fuck this my space,
Facebook.
Fuck am I doing?
And then after a while I'm not sending you'll fucking text message to Joe Rogan.
You know?
Remember you had a whole video about you sending him text messages that he would
get angry.
He,
we'd made a video about,
it was one of the,
one of the earliest videos that they were called a,
that was a desk squad one,
right?
What number was it?
No,
that was Joe show.
Joey is ready to die.
Oh,
Diaz.
When he did die.
God Damn it.
If you can find that.
Is that online somewhere?
What's his home?
It's way.
It's fucking,
it's a brilliant,
brilliant video.
It's z as he was alive.
He's a science project.
We have Joey Diaz just sits you down and goes over all the substances dog all
the years,
all the pink Floyd albums.
I listened to mother Fucker,
if he,
if he wouldn't go over his history,
you'd be like,
there's no way he could be alive.
How's this guy?
How's it possible?
He's healthy as a horse.
Joey Diaz is a fucking savage.
I live to be a thousand.
It's amazing.
Isn't everything.
High School football players die on a field from dehydration and then you get
guys who wake up every day thinking how can I kill myself today?
And they're still,
well Joey's really helping now.
He lost a lot of good,
he lost like 80 pounds.
He lost a lot of way.
He cause he got real big for a while and it's suck cause like we would go places
like we would go to the airport and he hated when he had a like a long walk to
the rental car.
That's a bad sign.
It's like,
you know he would get,
he was getting big but he had you know and he didn't want to do it with surgery.
He just did it with his will.
He just got on weight watchers and slowly shut it away.
He could definitely raise much.
Was on the road though.
How did it help?
How do you cook the Shit and all?
I think it's like they give you like a point system.
I think the way it works is like,
you know,
pizza is x amount of points and this is that amount of points.
You get so many points a day and they have a broken.
Now we're really healthy things or like very few points.
Like I think like salary is like 0.2 get just eat salary by itself.
It's mostly water.
Yeah.
You can't even get it.
It actually is really good for your cleans,
your cleans,
your poop shoot out.
Well that's good to know.
Tremendous.
Tremendously Travolta.
I uh,
I drank this Kale shake that has a lot of salary and it was five stalks of
celery in it.
So I take every day five stocks or salary,
five stalks of Celery,
a big Bush or a big fucking leaf of Kale pairs,
garlic ginger,
and it grinds it all apart and makes it like a swollen,
like a,
like a soupy like pea soup.
Very much like pea soup and where you went in a cover of a magazine.
I was having a cup of liquid Lawrence.
Man,
I haven't seen that.
I want to say I just like split in half.
You're like doing a split.
Um,
one of 'em.
Yeah,
I think,
I think I was throwing like,
no,
you know why in the black belt one now it's just standing there like I looked
really stupid.
I should've never let them make me pose like that.
It's like once you like cross your arms,
look at the camera like very serious.
And so that's what I did and I was like,
who
was opposed to,
what message is that?
I should be smiling.
Do you think you could beat the two of us if we just charge you right.
I would hope.
I would never have to know.
How do she do I look and look at your old tattoo right there when my port
tattoo,
it's still there.
I got to get it lasered off to finish my right to leave the Aaron Dellavedova
sleeve.
That's Graphics Bong,
right?
No,
no,
no.
It's um,
it was a like a thing that I drew.
It was like a demon adjusters mascot.
It's so crazy because I always thought it was the graphics.
Damn.
That dude loves fucking we,
it's so stupid.
It's such a stupid little touch here.
Well,
I was an artist.
I actually drew that,
you know,
and when I was a kid I used to draw a lot of demons with like hats and deemed
like demons with baseball,
hats on and shit like standing over little kids' beds.
I used to draw some creepy shit and uh,
I drew that and so that was my first tattoo.
I just noticed it says Joe Rogan proves fear is not,
I guess I was in my early thirties.
Yeah.
Cause fear factor went on for like six years.
We were still in your 20s when I met you.
Yes.
Yeah.
When,
when we met,
I was really young.
You and I met when we did Montreal together.
We did a showtime,
I think I was only like 24 25 and then we,
we met in New York at the end.
David Brenner's pool.
Yeah,
we played pool together.
We met at a Amsterdam and Dom's one of the few weeks I brought my queue today,
dom was one of those guys.
We,
we threatened to play each other like once a month.
That's what we always say.
We tried to get,
but sometimes we'll go like years.
Did you just show me?
Oh,
that's the one I was talking to him about.
No,
if I was a gay man,
Oh shit I do at the end.
To me
I just did a new thing for this fighters only magazine.
Just at a more recent one or I don't look as good.
That's the last fight you've been in like a real fight,
like a fist fight,
like a street fight.
Not since I was a teenager.
Yeah.
I avoid everything.
She got to kill people the way you will or you get sick or shot or it.
Guess what?
It's a lot of people out there that know how to fight.
They might beat your fucking ass.
You know the idea of going around and getting in fights with people,
it's like most almost everything we could get along without that.
Almost every situation life could get along without someone beating the fuck out
of somebody.
Almost everyone I was saying and when it's not,
when you can't get along without it,
it's like,
well,
you're in the presence of some sort of a dangerous,
scary person who's not thinking clearly otherwise.
I think Brian and I go,
what do you think would win their fight?
Brian Wade.
He would just quit right away.
Get out of breath.
Are you ticklish?
I Dunno.
Like if I go over there and you just give,
never get tickled by a guy.
What if I just give you a little tickler,
right?
Yeah.
He just ripped his pants and he opens up his butt and the vision is so horrific
and it's your shirt falls down into his armpit so it's got hangs down and he's
just opening up as assholes.
Why is convenient?
You just run away.
You'll just run out what you want,
want none of that good.
What he's willing to do to you,
and then he come close to him.
We'll try to lick you or something.
It's like,
you don't know want that.
They don't want that.
He'll just grab your face and just start licking you.
I'm glad I had tongue kiss you tongue kiss you to get out of trouble.
He would tongue kiss you,
just grab you and just start making out with you.
When you would run,
you would run.
You know every animal has it's own way of defending itself in its environment.
Like act of Octopus's.
They blend in.
They become,
they can become camouflaged,
right?
Yes.
There's a lot of a lot of animals they blend in with the reef right down.
My rarer.
Yes.
That's why Nimo was so brightly colored.
Is that why it's amino could blend in with the reed.
I was hoping we get the name of the show.
I assume that's a beautiful fish.
Why?
Why would nature wants something so brightly colored?
Cause it's cute.
It's pretty fucking bizarre man.
When you think about the colors that nature is chosen and stuck with as far as
designs of things like tiger's like a big giant crazy killing machine that's
beautiful with like white and like different cost stripes to it.
It's not just like why does it have to have different stripes too?
It's obviously just fucking things up.
That's all this thing does.
Like it's not worried about anybody.
Like that thing has no natural predator,
so it's completely fearless.
So it was expressing itself as boldly as it wants to.
It's not hiding from shit.
It's on the the apex of the predators,
you know?
But why is it so beautiful?
Why is it colored like that?
Like what?
What benefit of natural selection was it that the Tigers that made it to
maturity and live the longest and decided to outbreed the others were the ones
that were brightly colored and beautiful.
That's wild man.
You know how we find new species all the time?
Wouldn't be cool if he found like new colors once in a while.
Like I just found this new color your mind?
Yeah.
Like if they just figure out like something that they can add like hard disk
space to your optical nerves and all of a sudden you see a broader spectrum of
colors or just a different color.
Like,
like imagine because we grew up with all these colors,
but if you just throw in a color into the mix and it will pull all the charts
and it's amazing that you guys grew up.
Doesn't seem to effect.
Yeah,
I,
I mean is it possible that there could be another color?
I don't know anything about color.
I don't know.
Because we have this whole graphic,
the color wheel and rainbows and shit to like go on as proof and like that's the
only thing that seller to spectrum.
But what if we,
there's something just throws a wrench into that mix and an hour you're like,
oh,
that.
Yeah.
I mean that has to have happened throughout history,
right?
Where they thought they figured out.
Right.
Well how about those assholes that we're using leeches.
Oh,
how the fuck did that over half the blood with,
he said doctors that were using leeches gone to doctor school.
Like,
I'm here to help.
well,
how about blood letting Joe go fucking do for a sick person.
It's like we're blood at the bottom.
Me.
And they thought there was bad blood inside of them.
There was so much stupidity when it came to the human anatomy and,
and how to fix things.
They used to use leeches on black eyes for they did when the swollen eye,
they put a,
she would suck the blood out.
You remember?
And Rocky,
the,
he couldn't see out of his eye mic actually asked him to cut him.
Come me Mick,
what kind
of nonsense done that door in sets,
but isn't that ridiculous?
Like no one ever done that.
Why did they put that in a movie?
Goddammit.
Sly.
I want some answers.
C'Mon Burgess burden is that guy is fucking,
we bigger than everybody says he is.
I am so tired of everybody telling me that Sylvester Stallone is like this
little tiny guy.
Like people have this some weird thing to take.
Guys like him and Tom Cruise go.
Yeah,
well he's only five foot wall.
right.
Yeah.
Well maybe he's got fucking billions and maybe it looks good at 70 but he's only
fucking five foot three.
But he does wear heels.
I'm five foot eight and he's bigger than me.
He wears heels.
He's whatever he's wearing.
He's a big guy.
I said,
let him a few times his physical with like,
he's a,
that's a thick dude,
man.
I tell you what he said to me,
which is fucking hilarious.
What'd he say?
That I met him at this thing to name drop was Bruce Willis was the opening in
Montreal for a planet Hollywood.
And very nicely though,
he comes up to me and I'm with Sophie and he goes,
Hey,
dumb,
I'm slow.
I don't know.
I met you in a Paul Rogers thing.
And I go,
yes,
I remember you.
I'm thinking in the back of my head.
I'm thinking then [inaudible] fucking rocky.
Do I remember you fucking kidding me?
I got a chance.
Interview him for a one of the UFC.
He was a,
it was,
I think it was before the expendables are one of it,
one of his movies.
And uh,
I got a chance to interview and I was like,
this is crazy man.
Because when I was a kid,
I mean every,
how many people have told them this story?
Uh,
I saw his movie and then I went out and ate raw eggs and ran around
trying to catch a chicken.
I eat raw eggs just like he did it.
I put on a sweatsuit and I ran around the block like a fucking idiot.
I was so inspired.
I hadn't done any martial arts training at all at this point.
What?
It was a little perfect movie for that kind of inspiration,
those,
Oh,
you know,
it,
it was so interesting how touching that's simple movie could be.
Yeah,
there was some,
we love watching someone try to pull something off.
People love underdogs.
You know,
I don't know if you know this,
but um,
the UFC light heavyweight champ,
Jon Jones just got into a car accident.
I don't know about this.
No,
he's okay.
He was drunk though.
And uh,
apparently allegedly the story is that he's the least.
I don't at least they arrested him for Dui.
Okay.
I don't know whether or not he was drunk.
I don't know.
I don't know the full particulars of the story,
but so many people are like shitting on this kid,
you know,
and,
and angry with them as they should be for anybody who's driving truck and
anybody who loses control of their car and crashes into a tree.
But I think there's a little extra venom about this guy because he's so
successful because he,
he's like,
it's come so easy to him and it's not easy.
Obviously it's hard work,
but he's been like dominating all these people and I think we like to shoot
people down when they get too big.
We like to look for the first flaw and this make no mistake about it.
There's no like apology for what he's done because what he's done scares the
fuck out of me.
The one thing that I'm terrified of is finding,
you know,
myself on the road and seeing someone who's drunk coming towards you who doesn't
have control of the car.
That's it.
It's a terrible feeling.
And we've seen drunks on the highway before.
It's,
it's,
it's a scary,
scary fucking thing.
So this guy loses control of his car and slammed into a pole.
And whenever the fuck cause him to do that,
that's bad.
That's fucking real bad.
But I think people were also like chipping away at this dude as a human because
he's been so successful so quick and because he sort of tries to promote himself
as like a,
you know,
a,
a god fearing man and you know,
he tries to promote himself as,
um,
as like a,
a good Christian.
And because of that,
you know,
when he makes a mistake and does something fucked up,
people like really go after him because you can't,
it's very difficult when you set like a big example,
you know,
and you want it,
you want to set an,
an amazing path for kids and then you do something like,
you know,
you say that's what you're doing and you,
you say you're going to be a hero for these kids and,
and then boom,
you have this horrible situation.
Everybody's waiting for Tim Tebow to fail.
Well,
yeah,
they're waiting for him to get pictures of him fucking a goat or something.
And I mean they would love that.
Look,
I think it's the whole thing is a,
it's a fucking tragedy on the human,
the human personality,
the human,
the individual that allows themselves to get to a situation where they smash a
car into a tree cause they're fucked up on,
on a drug.
It's,
it's scary
cause you're,
you're taking all of our lives at risk to with your,
you know,
your craziness.
No,
I just,
um,
well don't,
I just don't drive since the Ui,
how to Dui,
I don't fucking drive the thing.
The appeal of rocky
is the same appeal that we all want to see somebody rise up and stop the
unstoppable
made up a black guy.
And when someone's really good,
we want them to fail.
We secretly wanted Tyson to fail before he failed.
And then when he failed people,
like there was like a weight lifted off the world of like on the million men,
they like to see the bully knocked down.
Yeah.
And then never,
the show is never the same after that.
He never fought the same and they read the same confidence.
Well,
I think he had,
I think you can only maintain that sort of pace that he was doing.
You could only,
depending upon your personality,
but it can only go for a few years.
They,
the amount of ray was and it was menacing was it?
Oh,
he was the best ever.
You know,
everybody wants to say,
but Ali Ali was a great fighter.
No doubt about it.
Tyson was better.
I really think Tyson was better.
I think Tyson in his prime,
like the Marvis Frazier prime,
I don't think,
I don't think Ali would have been able to keep him off.
I was,
I was ringside on when he fought Leon Michael Spinks.
Oh,
Atlantic city.
It was a scare.
It was like up jumped the devil.
Oh,
I was like,
smoke was out of his nostrils.
Took shit to a whole new level.
It was unbelievable.
There was a bunch of guys when I,
this was like,
you know,
I was a big boxing fan in high school and this was around that time that Tyson
sort of rose to prominence.
Like right when I was getting out of high school.
It was like the cover of sports illustrated.
They called them wonder kid and he was 19 years 18 yeah,
yeah.
And he was fucking smash and people get mad you and he was like Robin Person.
Oh,
scary.
That would have been,
he was such a,
an amazing specimen.
But he's also intelligent and just the,
but the physical speed that guy had while maintaining,
you know,
two 2100 and whatever pounds he was,
it was incredible.
Now we'd do it.
We'd never had anybody that could punch that fast.
The Marvis Frazier fight is one of the worst Smallings in a professional
heavyweight fight ever of all time.
Well,
I'll tell you what was Beth and Randall Cobb when he got beat by Larry Holmes,
dad was in his band one that him to go down.
We're all friends and go down Randall.
Good.
Now I know he couldn't,
but it was horrible.
That was a,
that was her ferocious beating.
But you know what he did after that and he went to school and got a master's
degree.
That guy like he's got out of boxing,
did acting and I dunno if he suffers anything from his,
uh,
his mean his,
you know,
you talked to him,
then he repeats himself and it's no way around that.
And then you'll talk to him and a repeated himself.
There's no way around that.
That's scary shit.
You know,
uh,
getting,
getting struck in the head on a repeated basis.
And there's a lot of guys that,
um,
that,
that suffer with a called pugilistic dementia.
A lot of guys suffer it that never even go proud.
Just guys who have good Jim fine.
We know May,
may Ali,
you know her.
Yeah.
And she would tell him,
cause my father knows everything that's going on,
he just gets bodies just failing them.
But his mind is right there.
He's like trapped in his body.
Could you imagine,
ma'am?
Well,
you know,
that's what cracks me up about the football thing with like gold,
the research you're doing on concussions.
Of course,
their concussion of course.
Of course.
Every 40 seconds they were like in a car accident.
Yeah.
Well,
I don't know if it's that much,
but it's,
it's pretty horrendous.
Yeah.
If you look at some of those leads,
that's football.
They used to call him dingers.
What's the biggest linebacker they have now?
Who's the biggest?
I Dunno.
I Dunno who the biggest give me like a give me a big,
big fucking scared.
Like six five for a linebacker to 70 to 70 that'd be pretty big.
No,
but fast.
That's the thing.
You have to remember.
They're fucking fast.
Oh,
and they're hitting you with a lot of super athletes.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
There sure.
You know Herschel Walker is still beating the fuck out of here out of people I
know that.
Well,
48 years old.
He was a phenomena.
Yeah.
What a freak combination of like a guy who's completely driven is a natural
super acid.
Multiple correctable discipline.
He had multiple personality too.
Yeah.
He came in with different personalities and the therapy you heard about.
Yeah,
I did hear about that fucking crazy tandem.
Supposedly trauma induced like,
Oh,
I dunno.
I,
I thought that the,
that was one of the issues that this was something that is related to his
football career.
That,
I dunno,
but I just,
that he imagined him coming in as big sue.
Oh,
Jesus Christ.
Hi Big Sue.
How are you feeling today?
I'm gonna look this up,
but multiple personality.
Yeah.
It's what I think it is.
All of a sudden I'm a,
I'm a therapist,
but it's not,
it's not a psychosis.
It's a,
it's an erotic disorder person.
Erotic,
not neurotic.
Oh,
hey dom,
I find that Rodeo,
just listen.
Oh,
multiple personality.
Trauma induced.
Is that what it says?
Uh,
no,
I'm,
I'm a Google in that Sar Bible,
but I believe it did have something to do with it.
Yeah.
Trauma induced.
Yeah,
no kidding.
Yeah.
This sorta usually has its roots roots in childhood trauma.
Oh.
So it could be an emotional trauma to,
it could be that simple.
Had that.
Yeah.
Okay.
You remember civil?
Yes.
Very dear friend of mine,
Bobby and I used to get brunch.
Hey,
Stepford wives at the Beverly Hills Hotel.
Um,
okay.
Yeah.
Okay.
We'll,
he's talking also about how he became a completely different guy when he was
playing.
Okay.
Right.
Yeah.
He said his exact quote was,
you don't want the Hershel that plays football babysitting your child.
He's not crazy.
I'll put that baby.
She imagine that coming out of Hershel Walker's mouth.
How scary that would be.
No,
you do.
You do not want the Hershel that plays football.
Babysitting your child,
even though they would think of that.
Yeah.
Well he was,
he's ruthless.
I mean,
I think to get that good at something like as good as Herschel Walker,
was it football?
Yeah.
I really do believe that madness and excellence are just next door and Amaris.
I really do.
I think in order to,
to hit the,
the levels of proficiency that those guys hit,
like the true greats,
like a guy like Jordan Jordan is a good example cause he's fucking crazy.
Yeah,
of course.
One of those guys,
like when he did his acceptance speech for the hall of fame,
he was B was complaining about people who rejected him can instead of taking it
going,
hey,
I'm number one,
he,
he came,
came angry at it.
Wow.
That's so crazy.
Yeah.
Well there's a lot of people that,
you know,
they never,
they never find peace there.
Their life is always chasing something,
chasing,
you know,
a wind chasing a victory,
chasing,
uh,
whatever the fuck.
And I love that about standup Joe.
Like we can get better until we get fucking cocked on the head.
It's true.
But no matter what Jordan does,
no matter what nutrition he can go visit the,
the,
you know,
the monks and they,
Paul,
nothing's going to make him Michael Jordan again.
Yeah,
the physical Bonnie Wayne's a lot quicker than the mine,
but we're going to be shitting our pants and dying in fear.
Just like,
Hey,
you'll be walking me.
You'll come and visit me at the home before he'll come and visit you.
Well,
who knows?
Who knows how we all go,
but it's not going to be,
it's not going to be good.
But Herschel is a at 48 years old,
it's fucking shredded,
shredded.
He,
I don't know if he's going to fight again,
but he's had a bunch of MMA fights.
I think he said three.
Well he's the one that used to do like 2000 sit ups and the downs does still
does that crazy shit.
He's all does all calisthenics.
They just fucking,
just a freak.
He's so God damn strong.
He texts these guys like,
I mean,
he's good.
He's physically talented like a,
I know he's like a brag black belt in some martial arts,
karate or taekwondo or something along those lines so you physically knows how
to kick and punch.
And then,
you know,
he's been training at Aka,
which is a big gym up in San Jose.
One of the like big gyms in the country as far as MMA is concerned.
Like Josh Koscheck came out of there.
John Fitch.
Um,
a lot of good guys.
Like real good.
Uh,
Gilbert Melendez.
no.
Excuse me.
Josh Thomson Rather,
uh,
came out of there and Gilbert Melendez and him just fought this past weekend.
Fucking incredible fight.
Holy Shit.
That was amazing.
When do you announce a fight again?
Uh,
this weekend.
This upcoming weekend.
Whereas Vegas,
fuck,
I love it.
I think you're so fucking good at that.
It's fun.
Well thanks.
It's a,
it's,
I don't make it make it the Sami Moreland show,
but he was really,
you really break it down and you make people understand that.
Like I told you that before.
It's like so much fun because your enthusiasm,
but you know what you're talking about.
But you're not above like,
I don't even know what the fuck some guys are talking about.
He threw a right Kloss Sangha,
you know they're making,
yeah,
there's a little of that that goes on where they get like real sports specific.
I will say like,
he hit him with the three,
two and you know,
dig in with the five.
Like,
come on man.
How many motherfuckers out there watching at home know what a five is?
You know,
I don't know.
It's,
it's,
but punches are w one is the jab to a straight run.
Okay.
Three's and left hook fours.
Right.
Africa it depending on who wins this time.
Huh?
Sorry.
Probably will live her.
Huh?
I don't know.
I don't even know what it is.
He can't go that far and not taught me to fight.
Well what he,
you know,
they'll,
they'll go as far as,
uh,
like trying too hard to get a lot of like sports guys that do that.
They're like try too hard to like use the correct phrases.
They'll say like exotic shape,
they'll get it wrong.
Like this is a Kamora what's now Americana?
It's quoting me,
you know,
it's different situation.
See how the grip is.
It's totally different.
But you know,
they're,
they're calling it out anyway cause it sounds like the,
the cool sports guy thing to know that the,
the Omoplata is a good one.
There's a guy never know how to say that.
There's a guy named Walt Frazier who was an old guy.
He's played for the Knicks and he announces Knicks Games and he does that.
Yeah.
Does it was,
you know,
juxtaposition of the materialistic
grocer.
Remember when Dennis Miller used to make references like to the Tigris and
Euphrates river,
these fucking guys in Pittsburgh or watching the game drinking.
But what you're talking about the blood,
Dennis Miller had the weirdest act going on for a long time when he was on
Monday night football.
I'm talking about Oh yeah,
he,
well he pissed a lot of people off on that didn't he?
Because he was trying to like insert jokes into it.
Yeah.
But I mean also,
but his references and they,
you know,
they're like one time I did enjoy his first two specialties.
A good like his first,
he before it became all crazy.
Right.
Winger,
you've got a little deep end.
Little after nine 11 ish,
he went a little pro Bush ish.
But uh,
you go back to like his earlier stuff,
he's fucking,
there's a very funny comic,
you know,
it's amazing.
I was asking one of the a writer and you know,
the guy,
and I won't say I'm on the air,
but he wrote for dentists,
Jon Stewart and Bill Maher and he said by far Dennis was the most decent guy to
work with.
He's a great guy to talk to him after his radio show a few times.
He's a great guy to talk.
Yeah,
he is.
You know,
I would notice a lot of guys that I enjoy talking to her.
Like there's a guy named Sam Harris that I had on the podcast and he's very much
like,
I thought he was a,
he's a,
he's a brilliant dude,
but um,
he shares a lot of like,
uh,
a lot of the same sort of,
ideas that a lot of right wing people share like about like the,
the good ideas about war and the good things that we're doing,
like going over to these other countries and the ignoring and the minimalizing
all the bad shit and ignoring and minimalizing all the damage that it does to
the societies and the fact that people are profiting from it.
See,
I would just like it explain to me like the way he was saying,
you explain a martial arts am a rather,
uh,
I was just like,
somebody explained to me why we're in Afghanistan.
What,
what the whole purpose.
I don't know.
I still don't fucking know it.
It's a massive mind fuck if you really sit down with someone who tells you on
one side that,
uh,
it's a,
an important thing as far as stabilizing that region and keeping out Haida from
getting a stronghold and blah,
blah.
But I,
Buh Buh Buh.
You know,
you,
you can listen to that and you go,
wow,
okay,
I see the point.
You know,
maybe,
maybe our military is working hard to keep us safe and they know better than us
and you know,
that's why they're there and they know,
they know that there's a threat there.
But then when you look at it on the other side and you go,
you know,
you talked to someone who is a very educated in the history of the ways of this
country,
and they explain to you what's most likely going on is that there's resources
over there that we need to control whatever the fuck it is.
Yeah.
The Russians couldn't beat him.
They could walk there.
Yeah.
Well we're,
apparently we were supposed to leave now,
you know,
that's what Obama saying.
You know,
Obama was having these things while he's running for reelection where he's
sitting down with Karzai,
who by the way,
Karzai's brother,
uh,
got he got somehow or another,
he got busted cell being in cahoots with the,
the,
uh,
the opium dealers down in Afghanistan and he was getting CIA money.
So this guy was like working with the opium trade,
getting CIA money when he's the brother,
the president of Afghanistan course.
But it's amazing how it's,
you don't even have to look for,
it's not like six degrees of Kevin Bacon.
It's like his fucking brother is in there with no degrees.
It's right there.
You know what,
man?
I don't know.
I look at both sides.
Both arguments of of the pro argument is very shaky in my opinion,
but I can understand this that I'm who,
same paranoia,
but the Afghanistan,
my brother Joe's a colonel in the marines.
I think the,
the thing is the worried about al Qaeda taking control of the era of the
Taliban,
taking control of the,
the,
the resources.
Apparently the idea is that there's a lot of money to be made and that they
don't have oil though has gotten us a lot of minerals.
A lot of men have trillions of dollars,
a minerals and there's natural gas.
That's what the Soviets were trying to control and then there's the opium trade
that people don't want to believe it.
But that's the reality is the,
the poppies,
the production has gone up through the fucking roof since America occupied.
I mean the,
all,
all the statistics are available online.
You know,
you can,
you can look at it.
People don't want to believe it,
but this,
they're not stopping it.
No one,
no one in the United States that goes over there and none of those army guys are
stopping the production of poppies.
In fact,
they're guarding poppy fields and that's a fact.
Americans are guarding,
guarding poppy fields.
That's hilarious.
People don't believe it.
Brion pull that shit up because we've,
we've had this on the podcast before.
That's how people heard about this before.
It's a nutty situation.
I don't,
and a lot of that stuff,
you know,
I don't know what they use it for.
If it's for pharmaceutical drugs,
which there that is a legitimate use bagels for that stuff.
Or if it's getting sold right into the heroin market,
I don't fucking know.
But to pretend that this isn't a factor,
that these trillions of dollars,
I old please conspiracy theory,
blah blah blah.
You're talking about something that generates just fucking insane amounts of
money.
Insane amounts of money.
And I wonder how much it has,
how much pressure,
something like this,
like some sort of a,
a business venture like this has on the introduction and the legalization of
other drugs in this country.
You know,
the only way they could pull off a heroin deal like this is if heroin is
illegal.
So everything gets moved in under the table.
Everything gets snuck in through,
you know,
a prearranged shipping routes.
Everything's clean,
desk dine,
you know?
That's really the only way to do it because otherwise other people are going to
do it.
Are we still getting hopium from Afghanistan?
Of course we are.
We must get through.
Where's it going?
Well,
I will look there.
They're making 90 plus percent of the world's opium in Afghanistan.
90 plus percent.
There's deaths.
That's insane.
I mean just that number alone is almost like a joke.
It's almost like this is a comic book.
Then we find out that the bad guy lives in a place where all the opium is and we
got to let these people grow.
The bad guy is the opium.
How bout that?
Help him takes care of the schools.
Just like in Botswana,
the diamonds to help.
They want to have find the enemy.
In Afghanistan it's heroin.
That's the enemy,
but if you like it,
go for it.
Especially if you're a musician because they make good shit when they're on
heroin.
A lot of them.
Do
you know Eric Clapton was just when he was on heroin?
Yeah,
I mentioned Hendrix before,
but apparently I've been corrected that a Hendrix didn't do heroin until after
he made his music.
He put out his studio albums and then he started fucking around with heroin
overdose.
He died on a bunch of Shit,
man.
And there's a lot of people that believe that he was murdered.
Like his,
his,
um,
former manager had a,
as a,
as a roadie and uh,
the road,
he just released a book
about it.
And the Roadie I think was also an abandoned self when he was younger,
like the animals or something like that.
Oh yeah.
And this,
I think that's the story.
And anyway,
the Roadie,
um,
apparently said that,
uh,
Jimmy,
had,
uh,
like a really fucking dangerous manager and his manager was like mob connected
and shit.
And he did a lot of fucked up things.
And one of the things he claims he did was kidnapped Jimi Hendrix,
his own manager had guys kidnapped Jimmy.
And leave him in a hotel for three days.
And then he rescued him in quotes to show him how powerful he is,
how he can get anything done.
And they all like,
please show we didn't,
we didn't know he was with you then.
I own this guy.
You stay with me,
Jimmy,
I'll protect you from these guys.
Well apparently he also had like,
you know,
there was a big life insurance policy that they're saying was a on Jimi Hendrix
down that the,
the,
the veracity of that,
I don't know,
you'd have to check.
I'm not really into it enough to,
I went to Wikipedia,
the latest who died in the,
who the fuck knows,
you know.
But the other thing was the Jimmy Hendrix,
a girlfriend at the time,
she was killed.
Somebody threw her off the top of a roof of a building in somewhere in New York.
But the speculation was that that had to do with Jimi Hendrix,
his death.
You know,
if you wanted to paint a beautiful,
uh,
conspiracy mystery,
and that's how you would go with it.
Whether or not that's true or not.
My favorite conspiracy was it goes back to Michael Jordan and they said that
because he didn't pay a lot of is a golf bets.
Oh yeah.
Well that was a big thing.
That was the other was killed over the,
Oh my God.
Yeah.
They,
let's father was killed in North Carolina.
Oh my God.
I said that was connected to them.
Who,
you know,
who knows.
Um,
so many conspiracy theories,
but holy shit,
that's scary.
He was a big gambler and none of that.
Well,
I know there was a,
an article that was written in like Esquire or one of those,
it was ask why or maybe vanity fair.
I don't remember what magazine it was,
but,
uh,
it was,
an article that was written by a guy who was a,
a golf hustler who,
uh,
Michael Jordan owed like a half a million.
Yeah.
He never paid up.
I heard it goes to places and bars and has dinner and doesn't pay just because
they,
you know,
he graced them with his presence.
Wow.
Really?
It doesn't tip,
they call Scotty Pippin.
No tip in Pippin.
Yeah,
I heard that.
That's so unfortunate.
It's,
it's amazing that a guy can get so successful and still be so selfish,
you know?
Maybe it's just,
he works so fucking hard that he just thinks everybody else's shit.
He's such a hard work.
Any bad ass motherfucker that everybody else is like,
bitch,
you want money for serving me?
Right.
The irony is he has the worst team in the history of basketball this year.
Oh,
he owns a team.
Bobcat's and there were the worst team ever.
Wow.
But he went from the being the groom split,
you know,
arguably the greatest player to the worst general manager over a wonder if he's,
do you think he's not a good owner or do I just doesn't have good,
I think he's got that syndrome where you remember the Al Capone thing where
everybody would laugh when he left and stopped when he stopped.
I think he has that a lot of yes.
People around
them.
So nobody says no.
So he makes moves that he's,
he doesn't really know what he's doing,
but there's nobody to confront him.
Nobody has the balls to confront him.
I think that's part of the problem.
Yeah.
That's the thing that people always look for.
The people always look for sycophants.
You know when you want to want to see a guy who was falling apart,
it looked towards a sycophants.
Yeah.
If you want to insult guys,
you call them sycophants right now,
which is always hilarious.
Like guys can't be friends now if one guy is more successful than the other,
while the rest are just sicker fans in the morons mine that,
that,
that's the conversation that comes up so that,
you know,
that's like demeaning to like all the other guys that hang out with a guy,
you know?
Yeah.
You find people change toward you in some ways.
Like in what way?
What do you mean?
Well,
deferring to you because they think they can get something or anything.
there's going to always be people that are weird man,
that just,
they're there,
they're trying to hustle,
they're trying to sell something and they want to get close to you because they
think it would be advantageous to them.
And you know,
there's this people that they,
they give it away,
man.
They give it away quick.
I didn't find that out yet.
People kind of hit on me for stuff that I really don't,
I can't,
I can't write them a strong act.
And of you think you could sit down right with me.
You're right.
It was just funny.
But I mean sometimes I think people want stuff that I,
I'm not even powerful enough to give him,
you know,
one thing.
What would it be cool to do a,
and I have thought about doing this before,
I think it would be really a ton of a fun thing to have guys like you and me and
maybe Stan hope or you know,
someone,
someone else weird along those lines.
Have like a series of guys have Joey Diaz do someone,
Ari Shaffir do something and um,
have it.
So comics will have like a meeting.
It felt like the,
you know,
the
Prov on like Saturday at like five in the afternoon and we'll just answer any
questions.
Oh yeah.
Wouldn't that be great?
Imagine if you were a guy had been doing comedy a year and a,
you could talk to the you of today just to ask you,
what do you do to,
what do you do?
How do you,
how do you get started?
What do you write about?
How do you write,
do you write it down?
Do you write bullet points?
What do you do?
Do you have the practice of deep practice it in order,
deep practice alone at home or only on stage,
the same order every time I had a guy,
it's been,
and it was so disappointed that I just told them the reality.
He said,
how do you get on the tonight show and those kinds of shows.
I said,
well,
the first,
you know,
the most important thing is very hard to write those sets cause I'm like you,
I'm more free form and I don't like to write tight sets.
And I mean,
but it's hard.
And he's,
I said,
you know,
you haven't really have to write him and you know,
construct them so that there are only five minutes.
And he goes,
you got to write.
I go,
well yeah.
What do you think you'd do?
Call up to president and show business and ask him for a favor.
It got it right.
What the fuck?
I didn't expect that.
Yeah.
Some people don't like writing.
I write in my head.
I uh,
I,
I've done that before and I'm not nearly as prolific.
I got to sit down prolific.
Well because you're working much till you
were so busy with my,
you know,
it seems like a lot of work,
but everything that I do is fun.
So it doesn't seem like work at all.
Still time consuming.
It's time consuming.
Yeah.
I mean it's very hard to crack the starting line,
don't you think?
Like you just got to do it.
The harder it is for me,
it's the better you get and the more strong shit you have,
the harder it is to break the starting line because you're thinking,
oh fuck,
I don't want to put that in.
It's not strong enough.
Well,
once you get it down,
like you get like an opening bid or a whole chunk down like fucking hard and
Japanese Samurai sword just folded over and
just Polish that bitch down to its lethal till just till it's perfect,
you know?
And you don't want to let it go,
but unfortunately you have to.
It's no other way.
Yeah.
We're doing a show here at the ice house Wednesday night.
Um,
what do you,
do you do anything Wednesday?
Um,
um,
I have one spot of the store.
What's up?
10 o'clock show.
We're doing a show here.
I'll come on.
We do set.
Sure.
What time's your spot?
The store?
10 o'clock.
[inaudible] Megan.
Yeah,
you could do it just late if you just do your set there.
And then if this source not too late as tour,
sometimes running late,
I can get along.
I can who sometimes don't even start at 10 o'clock.
We'll start like 10,
10.
We're crazy.
What's going to go to,
it'll go till at least midnight,
right?
Well if you come,
you know,
and,
and I'm moderating already on stage.
I'll bring her on stage.
All right.
And we can fuck around.
Okay.
Or do you just do your actor?
I mean,
I'll,
I'll introduce you at anytime.
Anytime you get here,
we'll throw you up.
That'd be awesome.
To the benefit.
No,
we're fucking around.
How much we're going to have a podcast at nine out of 10 and that's May 23rd.
If you're listening.
Yeah.
So if you're listening to this later and you want to come down the ice house,
can I plug a couple of days?
Please do.
I got Atlanta June 15th and 16th or they get a punch line.
Oh,
great club.
And uh,
when a big Gig for me,
because it goes to Philly,
is June 30th,
I'm at the Tropicana and the big room upstairs,
Tropicana in Atlantic city,
which I love.
I do love Atlantic city.
Well for me.
So we got,
we got all the fuck in a tie.
It's coming from Hamilton,
the mayor and everybody.
Well,
you know,
you,
uh,
you're one of those guys that you never stuck with the same act.
You know,
you're not one of those guys.
We'd go see him like three years later and you'll see the same shit verbatim
near always.
It was always writing.
You're always,
I fucking try it.
Love it.
You love it.
You're a,
you're a real comic man.
You're a real craftsmen.
You know,
you,
you could not have picked a better occupation.
It's not like dom,
every era should have been a plumber,
should have been an electrician,
should've been a doctor.
Whatever the fuck it was like.
It's the one thing,
my lack of talent.
Many things easier for me to focus.
Well you,
you've always loved comedy.
I mean since the moment I met you,
like we've had like so many conversations about comedy and I've got to see you
always working on shit and tightening shit.
Like you mean there's some guys and we all know them.
They just kind of this,
it comes a point in time.
They just start phoning it in.
But you never hit that,
you know,
you never hit that.
You're always,
even you.
Even that too.
You're always
saying like,
I'm trying to get better.
Like that's in your head all the time.
Absolutely.
If you're not getting better,
you're getting worse.
Yeah.
I don't stay at the one spot.
And what the fuck are you doing?
If you're not getting better,
you know,
what the fuck are you doing?
Why are you wasting your time?
Why I do so many sets?
Yeah.
I mean that's the thing.
That was fun too.
It's fun thing to do and make people laugh as a fun time.
New New rules.
My favorite.
I wish it could reenact that bit.
I love that bit.
That was a labor of love.
That bit.
There was a bit that I,
that was a bit that I was it,
what's her name?
She,
Anna Nicole Smith.
Smith.
Yeah.
That was the bit that I was actually forbidden from saying at the comedy store.
Mitzi came up to me,
show your fucking neck got longer.
Ooh.
The joke was
about,
you know,
there were,
everybody was like,
oh my God,
Anna Nicole Smith,
she's marrying this old billionaire that's so horrible.
Like what she's doing is so terrible.
She's taken advantage of him.
And my joke is,
don't you think he fucking knows?
He's 90 years old.
He made $1 billion from scratch.
Chances are the dude's a tad crafty
and it was him getting her to do all this crazy fucked up shit or you wouldn't
give her money and it just give kidding,
nutty or 90 or as he was dying,
he wanted her to lick his ass screaming.
It's like,
it was one of my favorite bits to do because it was like there was like it was,
it felt justified.
You can get away with it.
I don't know.
You were talking about then how the new rules come in when he do something
perverted.
Oh yeah,
you can't do this in the hospital.
She says,
he goes,
look my ball and she says,
sugar,
I would love to stay here and be with you,
but that the visiting hours of between nine and 11 he goes,
no,
I just bought the hospital new rules like my ball 24 hours a day.
I love that.
Fuck a bit.
He would listen.
He would be in a wheelchair man and she'd be standing over him.
This insanely hot,
big titted gas model.
And you just look at it and go,
oh my God,
that fucking body.
She had just this insane fuck body giant Jayne Mansfield.
When those early pictures,
like when she was in playboy or whatever the fuck she did,
you look at her body and go,
Jesus Christ with a body,
that woman that just all voluptuous and legs and you know like you,
when I like dom,
we don't like it.
No skinny broad.
I like a little meat on the bone,
you know,
I got a girl I can take a good fucking cause you know I deliver.
Oh,
I know.
I like the bang a and hit a wall the whole time.
I like to deliver.
Oh yeah.
That's my best impression.
He's one of my best impressions,
right?
I went to a strip club in Cleveland and it was one of the most,
like the name of the club was the name of the club was I Iran or it's
sexy secret or something like that.
Something was something sexy,
secret,
something secret and a it.
So I walk in and,
and I was the only white person in the whole entire clubs of like the secret
was,
I was the only thing,
you know,
it's,
but it was crazy.
I see chic secretive,
we go rob,
but I immediately got swarmed like it was like Zombie style.
Like what you've one by one.
All the strippers like looked over.
I was like wow.
White Guy.
And it like came over and at one point I had like two girls on each,
like lap one girl give me me,
me and massage to can't support two girls on each leg.
That's ridiculous.
That's a lot of weight.
Huh?
Two girls on each leg.
So you've got four girls on your lap.
No,
no too.
I'm sorry.
I grow on each leg.
Oh,
and I'm sorry,
I'm at two girls.
Two girls,
one on each leg when it needs like a lot of weight too.
But that hurts after a while.
That's not,
yeah,
they weren't very boney.
Yeah.
She,
you gotta step up.
Your fucking left leg is numb,
right.
Fall down and smash your face in the cocktail glass.
But they just like took turns like putting their butts in my face and like it
was so much but like I felt but juice on my arms like Lego is moisturizer or
something like that.
After a while it was so hot in there.
But anyways,
yeah,
check out a black strip club in the ghetto sometime.
It's pretty weird.
You okay?
Well no it's really interesting like juice.
Did you
you lead,
let them sort of get but juice on,
you know all over the place.
The thing is,
you know how you got to like it,
like a normal strip club,
lego what you're used to and it's like it's,
it's all about like big boobs.
Perfect body,
nice bud or something right there.
It was all about huge fucking bubble acids.
Like just girls,
normal looking girls but with like ink I think but in plants or something it was
all about bucks.
Can I ask you something?
Have you ever been officially diagnosed?
No.
I went to a strip club in Philly and it's black chick asked me for a lap dance
and I said,
no thanks you.
She said you're a racist.
And the book,
the Bouncer was black,
big guy.
And he knew me and I go,
what did he go?
What'd she say?
I,
as you said,
over racist.
What?
The fact that I don't think you're hot.
How rude.
Yeah.
How's that make me a racist thing to say to me while there you are.
Hold on.
Sorry.
Because we were all there.
You are arguing.
Let a stripper that's never win.
New thing to say when a stripper like what's happening to my license?
You Go,
I'm sorry.
I would love to.
But actually you look so much like my sister and that will freak me out.
Oh,
that's good.
So I said,
wow,
that's good.
Oh my God.
That guy,
I think he's really cute and he totally wanted to dance,
but I look like a sister and that is kinda creepy.
Yeah,
that motherfucker.
He said,
I love magazines.
I'm going to start a fight in the dressing room.
Right.
And then I'll come out and fucking shank you.
Maybe you were like that close to death and you don't even know.
No,
I think I was fine.
It was,
it was,
it was pretty amazing.
Now how they just warm to me,
like all these other guys kind of getting pissed because
I committed to getting purse.
Yeah.
CLEVELAND,
it was like by the plats.
I forget the name of Joe because I know it's a strip club there in front of
mind.
It gave lit this girl like $1,000 because you said she was studying classical
music,
some shit.
She believed him that he believed her wheeling can imagine she was studying like
the,
the oboe or something,
you know,
um,
some high falutin musical school.
It can't even remember the name but Julliard or something,
you know,
it's like give me a fucking break.
You know,
how many girls do like are strippers and have like high functioning jobs on top
of that?
Not many.
Do you know,
there was like,
there's like a,
um,
a check who got fired from somewhere,
I forget where she got fired from,
but she writes for like a local paper that you're,
I think it was like the Houston chronicle or something like that.
And she was,
she was writing a column,
but she was also like on the side,
she was a stripper and I found out,
so they fired her.
Somebody like turned around and so they fired her.
I,
you know what I think I would be if I was a woman in some extra cash,
first of all,
but anybody that would turn her in like that,
like I guess it's,
if it's a moral thing,
you're silly and it,
it's not a moral thing.
You're a cunt white.
Why are you turning her in?
Like,
yeah,
there's no upside.
Why you?
Why are you getting her fired?
She's work ad person,
you know,
she's just out there hustling.
I didn't give a fuck.
Just keep it yourself and now you can go see her naked.
What's wrong with you?
Right.
If you've got a weird thing with somebody,
the best thing to do is go visit them while they're naked.
Right?
Yeah.
Give resolve that shit.
I gotta Kinda stripper stripper bitch.
Like I'm serious.
Brian's like,
really man,
I'm trying to break down like the whole stripper and boyfriend relationship.
I'm trying to break it down.
Brian.
I'm trying to like,
uh,
you know,
you have to have a certain mentality.
If you're gonna date of girls and active stripper,
I can,
it really got to be able to let things go.
You gotta let things go.
Well,
how about those dudes that day?
Porn stars,
they're only allowed to fuck while you were at work.
Can't fuck.
Yeah,
I'm the boss around here.
Have rules like that.
You're allowed to fuck people,
but only while you're working.
So these dudes just working all day every night.
Imagine she's a mother to like the mother of my children.
And then a lot of them are,
a lot of them are,
you know,
there's,
there's girls that they have babies and then look,
what are they going to do?
They can make a lot of money doing porn or they can make no money not doing
porn.
So they either do porn or they go into you feature dancing.
It's a fucking grind out there,
man,
for everybody.
You know?
And if you're a chick that's banked on your looks,
you know,
there's,
there's guys that,
uh,
they think they're going to be professional pitchers and they're fucking album
blows out.
Everybody makes a risky,
risky gamble in this life.
We're all one,
we're all one pitch away.
Yeah,
we are.
Yeah.
If you look at it that way,
dollar Joe Rogan,
I try to be as fair as possible,
don't you?
Yeah,
absolutely.
It's my life's about the balance of justice.
Yeah.
A balance of justice.
That's a good way of putting it.
You know,
I got offered to go in a coal mine and it was a mile and a half deep and I
declined it,
but he was telling me how you champ travel on this thing.
I forget where you lay back and you have your,
your,
you're laying on your back and you just go down this whole slowly,
you know,
a mile down or something.
And uh,
he's like,
dude,
if you want to go,
we can totally do this whenever you want to.
You know.
And I was like,
fuck no,
I would,
I would rather not.
I'd rather try to commit suicide and then to do that.
That sounds scary as fuck.
Yeah.
Why are people into doing things that are really terrifying?
I don't know.
I don't think they have a choice.
Yeah.
Coal miners or can you imagine being a coal miner and no way that's it.
There's a show that they had on spike that I only could watch one episode
because it freaked me out so bad.
It was cool.
I think it was called coal and was a reality show about coal mining.
It's fucking terrifying.
There are deep,
deep,
deep inside just fucking mountain hope,
but it doesn't do this.
Boom.
They're pulling out giant chunks of it so they're going to make it brittle.
I mean,
and you know how brittle coal is anyway,
man.
When you feel cold,
you know brutal coal is coal breaks.
It's not like it's,
it's,
it's not steel.
You know when you feel it,
like you could chew into it with those machines and they pull it out of there.
He can crack and move and shit.
And about the guys that were down there and chill age.
There were beaten like a month or something.
Then they send them flashlights.
There'd be really no,
he imagined here's water and here,
fuck,
this is the first one as a candle so you can look each other in the eye while
you're doing it.
That's a butterfly.
You gotta you gotta Kinda cleaned it off though.
So save the water number.
One guy had a wife and a girlfriend.
They found out when he was there.
He's the guy's balling.
What are you gonna do
you imagine being in a situation where that's the only way you could feed your
family is to be,
you have to go to work in a mine.
That's really scary shit to be like one of the people that's responsible for
like pulling chunks out of the earth so that we can use it.
When you look at like humans in the relationship that we have to the earth,
it's so parasitic and strange and we never consider it that way.
We look at it as natural resources,
but if you looked at the earth is like a living organism.
We got to go inside of it and pull shit out of it that we use to light things on
fire.
On the surface,
we will literally have our whole society run on the blood of the earth.
The whole thing's run on oil.
Everything is run on some black liquid that is a fucking trillions of gallons of
it inside the earth and we're sucking it out and we're pretty sure it's finite.
It has to be fine.
We don't even know what's going to happen.
If it is finite,
what happens there?
It's going to implode.
What's he's going to light on fire.
What the fuck's going to happen?
Is it gonna?
Is it gonna spin faster and will days we'll go shorter will die instantly or the
fuck knows that.
That's bad science.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I don't believe in any of that.
I don't want to get any angry Twitter messages.
The twilight zone.
I remember the morning sun,
the one
that the episode where they thought it was getting harder every day and because
of the earth had fallen out of its elliptical orbit and it was coming closer and
closer to the sun and it was,
everything was stem.
Finally,
the painting started melting and they know who's over holy.
She wakes up and she finds out that just the opposite,
the earth is going farther away from the sun every day.
It's getting colder,
so it just shows the relative to the fragile existence,
which we have.
Anyway.
I'm Dom Arrera.
You guys have been great.
I liked the Obama crowd out.
A lot of guys that go for the left,
not me.
It is a,
it is true though.
We live in a delicate,
yeah,
balance.
I mean you think about,
we don't experience it here in California,
but when I lived in Boston or anybody on the east coast knows there's a vast
difference between what it's like to go outside in January and what it's like to
go outside in August.
A fucking world of difference.
I'd rather have January,
which really?
Well then I'd rather be in a 10 degrees on 110 for sure.
Really?
Oh yeah.
That's interesting.
Is that because of just,
you've spent too much time out here because they're gonna hate me,
so can I remind,
you know,
I just didn't ever,
I never liked he,
I'm really hot tub sauna like it.
I like it hot.
You like Vegas in the summer?
No,
that's too hot.
That's crazy.
That's silly planet,
Huh?
I like 90 degrees.
I like going outside when it's 90 degrees,
especially east coast 90 degrees because it's funky and sweaty.
I think it's healthy.
It's good for you.
I think she agrees with what a Thong on a couple boys,
his down on my clogs getting tea and dirty,
dirty toenails got big Afro wig paper all over my chest.
That's an image you'll never forget.
I started the show it that.
It's not just not the,
well,
I've never forget it.
It's just what we could all relate what everyone could have seen themselves in
that sense,
especially if you do need to get an expected to get woken up.
Oh Jeez,
where are we going?
Where are we going?
That's a good album cover.
If you ever happened,
yo wouldn't be hilarious if it was the actual photo.
If you realized it and he said,
oh my God,
here,
hold my camera,
take a picture of this.
I just remember him pointing at it.
What's that tape roll over?
Up to my neck is a little areas,
loads shift of
our time on this earth is spent devising new ways to get rid of loads.
I would say 35 35 to 40% I mean think about some of the relationships that you
have.
We're really just exchanges from a load extract and contractor.
Yup.
You know it's like there's,
there's relationships at guys have,
especially like young men early on in life when you're essentially,
you know,
you don't,
you're like a vampire that must feed and you only have so long we can go before
you start going crazy.
Started,
started dating somebody like I'm pretty close to feeding.
Here we go.
And then once you get close enough so you can actually have sex by the time you
do that.
Most of us have already compromised our position considerably.
And the relationship that we've agreed to and relented to is completely not,
we're looking for,
you know,
we just,
we just had to get some sex in,
you know,
is it's impossible to avoid.
So we tried to pretend to be the guy that you wanted us to be because that's the
way you get late.
It's becomes a junkie situation and becomes a situation where you're making
irrational decisions.
You're hoping that it works out and the person you wind up fucking is someone
you actually like and you'd just compatible personalities get together and you
raise a family or whatever you're hoping that you get to that situation.
But most of the time you don't.
Most of the time you completely incompatible.
Kellum made someone and they're fucking,
they're all sorts of problems and complaining and whining and Bullshit and,
oh,
the funniest one in the Dub David.
Oh yeah,
very much.
Here's the funny guy,
his whole,
you know,
you gotta talk to him sometime about this because he did it.
I thought he took the ring off to girl while she was asleep,
but he just stole it from the dresser.
But in the middle of the night he unengaged himself by taking the ring back.
Oh my God.
And her waking up the next day and he,
but he got engaged in like two weeks.
What does this fucking movies,
some people they,
they want that,
you know,
cause it's a fun thing to think of,
to love junkie.
It's like the love of that feeling,
that instant magic.
Well yeah,
everybody wants that.
Everybody wants to knock one out of the park.
They want you meet someone and you know,
she's,
she's nice and she's friendly and she's interesting and Oh my God,
I just know it's the one dom I only know for four hours,
but I'm telling you,
I'm marrying this girl tomorrow morning.
I already asked her to marry we fuck five times already.
We've known each other for four hours.
Like what?
There's people that throw themselves with abandoned.
It's because they want someone to believe in them.
They want someone to love them the same way.
They want to love someone.
They have this massive need to both love and be loved.
They are there in a love deficit.
So when love comes along,
they fucking throw a shit fit.
They go crazy.
They abandoned their friends,
they stopped answering her cell phone.
They'll throw their phone in the toilet.
I don't care.
I'm just by your side.
As long as I'm with you,
I don't want anything else.
We are complete.
You make me complete maybe complete time era.
They just ready and it was soaking.
I only dated once before she moved in.
Shazamm son.
That's what I'm talking.
That's how dom do.
No,
but I mean the thing is the list of nine years.
But that was a very rare situation when she moved to China.
And the only way I was going to get her to come back was prior to move.
In.
How many comics do you know that have healthy relationships?
Uh,
that's a good question.
I'd have done seven.
Seven.
Seven is,
uh,
it's,
I think it's a,
especially art.
Yeah,
I think it's especially hard in any sort of a,
a creative sort of a,
a job.
You have to have a cool chick understands that.
Do you have to have someone who lets you think you have to have someone who
gives you a space,
you know it's not all up in your grill constantly.
Yeah.
Which also have someone,
when you talk to they'll like they're,
they're fun to be around.
Your brain works.
Yeah.
Their brain works and they,
the,
they have a positive spin on things.
Like there's certain people,
we all know this like when you meet them and then you,
you see them and you smile and then you become enhanced.
You know what I mean?
Like Joey Diaz,
perfect example.
What's up baby?
What are we doing here?
And you see him and we would all start smiling and we feel enhance.
And there's other people that come around and they drag on you.
You know,
there's other people that come around and they just start complaining and
whining and bitching.
And I've had both men,
I've had both.
And it's,
there's the life of a you,
if you're with someone that complains all the time,
that some of the takes that negative point of view all the time.
Your life will be hell.
It's gut wrenching.
A friend of mine said there's two people in love.
There's fountains and drains.
Aww,
that's beautiful.
And that's true.
But like when those drains,
they just,
you know,
it's like,
how you doing?
I'm hanging in there.
No,
it was a brutal,
brutal.
There's a comic that I know I love him to death and I won't say his name,
but I,
I spoke to him once and I said,
I'm never talking to some mother fucker again.
I go half session of them.
I can't,
it's too,
he's too obvious.
Oh really?
No.
Making that up too.
I was throwing people off the track now.
He was parked cat.
I grew up in Afghanistan.
Um,
but you know,
I w I would say,
hey,
what's going on with,
well not so good.
I'll tell you the whole situation.
The wife,
she walked out.
Okay.
You know,
she walked out on you miss [inaudible].
I thought,
I thought this was the,
so something that we'd both agree to and apparently she had to agree to that and
like,
oh Geez,
you mother fucker,
listen to yourself.
So you,
I haven't seen you in years and you just hit me with a,
a just a bucket of diarrhea.
You know what kind of,
you know,
just that there's people that don't even think at all about the person they're
talking to.
All they think about is like the shit that they want to,
they want to,
they want to burden you because their life has taken some terrible turn for the
worst.
Mostly a lot with a lot of people because there's shit personality,
you know,
that people just go fucking get away from me.
Oh,
they just run.
And then that same shitty personality is what you makes you get trapped by this
guy at a fucking party.
Do you know Jeremy Huts?
Uh,
the comedian from Canada?
I do not know him.
Okay.
He's fucking hilarious.
Yes.
Very good comedian.
Very hilarious.
I've only seen him in a video.
He was serious.
We were doing Russell Peters a special and mature is,
and he was my roommate and he'd come in,
hi.
Hi.
Hey Jeremy.
Hey Dude,
you don't have any tums?
Do I got like a bad stomach?
I said,
no,
I don't carry toms.
He goes,
you got any beer?
I go,
look,
fuck goes from tums,
the beer,
cheese.
You know what I mean?
But it,
but he was always like a,
and he's so fucking good on stage,
but he was such a,
I mean,
I still enjoy him,
but he is such a bummer,
you know he's been well in that sense.
You know,
like he's talking about his sinuses.
One night at the laugh factory,
there's a bunch of committee I said in Chariton Lynn Tase him.
No Co Group of Comedians is going to be concerned about your sinus no matter
what,
unless you have your sinuses removed.
It's not an interesting story.
We don't want to hear about your fucking postnasal drip.
Yeah.
I'm not in to be around people that complain about stupid shit that you just man
up and deal with it.
Yeah.
He's saying knows bugs.
Just deal with it.
Right pitch right.
God dammit.
I went through most of my life with a broken nose.
I broke my nose when I was five,
fell down a flight of stairs and for most of my life I had like shitty breathing
out of my nose was all fucked up.
Yeah,
it was a mess.
It was all,
and then from getting punched in the face from wrestling and kickboxing and
taekwondo,
just always getting hit in the fucking face.
I'm don't know how many times I got hit in the face,
so the inside of the nose,
it was just a mass that I had like one little baby channel.
They opened it up,
they cleaned it all out.
It was one of the best things I ever amazing that you didn't even know where you
were.
Listen,
my mom's mouth breathing those mouth breathing for a giant chunk of my life and
I was trying to do like hardcore athletic.
So I was trying to do martial arts and with a broken nose I useless.
Knows
that was my notes,
literally.
But now it's like,
ah,
now I can breathe out of the operation.
Couple of years ago,
a few years ago,
I made a,
it was,
it was so important to me that I made a little video,
knew you when you were all died.
We'd probably got worse.
It got worse as time went on it.
And then I broke it again in,
um,
in like 2007 I broke,
I broke up pretty bad.
Those,
it was pretty bloody.
And I got black eyes and shit from,
from a,
Ha we,
I headbutted,
we collided Jujitsu class.
Jujitsu is,
you know,
the two things that happened to hurt Ya.
One accidental collisions.
Like sometimes you'll be throwing up a need for a triangle and you hit someone
the eye and it fucks are eye up.
It's happened to me.
I've done it accidentally.
It's just a,
it's just one of the things that happens.
Another thing that happens is sometimes people that are rolling right next to
you collide in you and you bonk heads and shit.
That's fucked up.
I've had that happen.
When you get hit pretty fucking hard.
I got suckered in a bar.
I was,
I was a doorman,
the bar,
uh,
me and Randall Cobb would have doormen really?
And Joe,
I don't fucking know anything.
They went,
what year was this?
I Dunno.
78 aware in Philly at a place called Doc Watson.
But it was mostly when Randall Tex cap.
Do you have a picture of you two together?
But he,
you know,
he was,
he was the North American,
a heavyweight karate champion at the time.
Yeah.
That's what a lot of people don't know.
He was a of kickbox.
Oh,
he could kick over your head,
man.
He was,
he had,
and each,
the first thing he showed me was his nose.
He had no cartilage in it knows,
it's magical.
But anyway,
I got suckered by this guy and broke my nose.
And the worst thing was it wasn't the pain.
It was the sound of them putting it back in place.
You know,
like with the local appliers they take,
well,
when,
when I got my,
um,
my nose fixed,
the boogers that came out were so horrendous that I saved them and I took
pictures of him.
You want to look at it?
Would you look at
asteroids?
I'm just going to show it to you because you're not even gonna believe it.
What is this?
This is when he had the check.
This is right after this is a,
I would have to blow snot out and I would use a waterpik and throw it through my
nose to clean my nose out.
It's pretty deep.
It's pretty intense.
Oh,
special
nostrils attachment.
Oh Jesus.
Is that,
it's like a lead salute the way you ain't seen shit sign.
Wait til you see these boogers.
No,
I'm gonna pull out.
If you email him the m I could show like the audience.
Okay.
Let me find the really good ones cause they're so ridiculous.
But you know,
my,
what was happening was that my body was,
um,
you know,
making these slots you're throwing up some me knows.
Yeah.
I kind of find them.
I don't know where they are though.
Unfortunately.
They probably deepen this I photo well,
that would give us a good excuse to get together and new to,
here's a picture of it.
Here's a still photo.
One of my boogers.
Yeah.
Hold on,
let me,
there was so ridiculous.
I think I put them on Twitter.
Did I put them on Twitter and on?
But I think the beginning of this video right here,
I definitely put them in the middle.
Oh yeah.
That's actually the clot.
The doctor pulled out my notes just so shit I showed,
I showed Tomi Segora yet at the airport and he almost threw up.
I got,
I'm real close to throw it up.
He had to turn away.
He had a hold his mouth.
It was pretty bad ass.
I think I'm closing it out of here.
Dumb.
I think that was the first time I met Tom Segura is that weekend right after he
had that operation,
this certain shit that,
you know,
if you can get it fixed,
man,
if you have a deviated septum and you get it affects your life will change you,
you will have a,
uh,
an easier life.
Like it's hard when you only can breed that of your fucking mouth.
That sucks.
But you can get some sleep apnea.
Beautiful.
I just found it.
Is it 100% though?
I mean,
could you go back right now and having sex?
It
look at the size of that God damn a date.
It's like a jewel.
Email it to me.
Email it to you right now.
That's disturbing.
How does so do you think you could go back and they could actually fix it up
even more?
I mean,
no,
it's clean now.
It's awesome now.
Yeah.
No,
it's 100% but it's,
it looks as different colors in it.
Yeah.
It's crazy.
It shouldn't even be real beautiful about it.
Yeah,
it's disgusting.
Hot.
You can reduce the message.
I don't want to reduce it.
Actual size,
actual size white,
trying to save gigabytes.
Rising sent,
sent the photo of the booger and not even the best photo of it.
It's,
it's,
it's so ridiculous.
It doesn't even look real.
It doesn't look like it could come out of your nose and it came out in one giant
super satisfying.
Honk
is another photo of it.
That's a closeup.
Jesus Shit.
Yeah.
It's like crystal that came out of my nose.
But I tell you what,
man,
for me,
that shit was sweet relief for me.
I know you're looking at and go,
Joe and I want to see your snack.
Then why you're looking,
bitch,
we told you what we're going
to do.
Listen,
I'm feeling bad that I'm showing these people this and that.
They're going to get sick.
Brian.
Let's kill it.
Kill it.
I think we made our point.
It was,
but for me,
man,
that that represents freedom.
That's my shackle.
Quite the host.
I feel fantastic.
I breathe out in my nose.
You look good as well.
Thanks Joe.
I feel good doing a lot of stretching now.
Are you a updating your Twitter?
You've been getting on Twitter?
Let me say it was the last time he got on this water.
How do you,
what's my Twitter?
It's dom Irrera you fella dumb.
Rarer.
That's it.
Yeah.
It's not at time.
I right.
It says at del Mar area,
everything's at,
we were just saying the other day about how,
remember when people used to like use the APP as if it's like them in the third
person is going to the movies right now.
People tried that for awhile.
Right?
Remember it got too pretentious stuff.
Do you tweet a lot?
Yeah.
Tweet all the time.
You know what's the best thing that I get into a habit of it?
It's,
it's some,
it's fun really.
It's really fun.
If you,
if you're interested,
Don,
my rarer,
the two r's are in the first position.
It's d o.
I even myself have fucked up upon occasion and made it I r e r.
R a like Carrera.
Right.
I have a friend.
I worked the club and they misspelled there as well.
I don't even know.
That's how career he spelled it at the club.
You worked at some mother fuckers,
Bro.
Captain Brian's off the hook.
Christ.
Where's that place?
Marco island.
It's dead to me.
It's a great place actually.
Marco island.
Oh fuck.
Beautiful.
Florida is fucking crazy,
isn't it?
Yeah.
Florida's crazy.
On a totally different level.
That's not the,
the rest of the country.
Florida is love it and I loved that Improv in Hollywood.
Hollywood,
Florida.
Oh that's a great place.
The Indian casino.
Hard rock.
Cause I did tell him to Joe,
mom,
make sure you don't say anything about the seminars,
anything bad.
They go like,
I got 15 minutes on the Seminole Indians.
They actually said that to you.
Wow.
Of course I went up and said nothing but good things about them.
You know,
just cause like somebody is going to tell me what to say.
I go,
I got to say something of all the tribes just seminar on my favorite.
I'm not,
I'm not a big fan of the Apache and Arapahoe and go fuck them.
I love the seminar paper.
So what could they say?
The Seminoles,
a sponsor,
a bunch of a professional pool matches.
Oh,
do they?
Yeah,
they still have a whole tour.
The Seminole Indians,
uh,
used to,
Seminole tribe brother used to be,
I don't know if you're allowed to call.
He's supposed to call them Indians come.
Why would you call them Indian?
Native American.
Yeah,
it's natives,
you know,
because like,
or colors the idea that we called them Indians like deep into the 20th century.
It's really pretty fucking crazy.
Indian come from Columbus.
Oh,
he thought he was going into you.
Right.
She's fucking assholes.
Get in the ocean.
We're in India.
He saw these little brown people.
These are Indians like they have no idea they were in The Bahamas.
The whole thing is preposterous.
It's really funny when you stop and think about that.
They still celebrate Columbus Day.
First of all,
Columbia's never even came here.
Well I should have Italian.
Have you ever read some of the shit that Columbus did?
Leave ferns.
It was Leif Erikson was waves the viking.
No,
but he was the first one here.
Wasn't here.
Well now not even work.
The red.
No,
they've actually found the really crazy thing is the oldest bod did they found
in North America and west Chinese.
So I love a bitch that Chinese are everywhere.
Well there they don't know like they're trying,
they're still trying to figure out like when people got in ships and traveled
all over the world.
By the way,
uh,
we are going to do a podcast with John Anthony West.
Speaking of this cause this is a fucking fascinating topic.
I've been exchanging email,
I owe him an email but he wants to do,
we're probably going to have to do it on Skype.
It may be the first time we ever do one on Skype,
but it's worth doing it for this Guy John Anthony West,
if you don't know is the guy who's like the main egyptologist who's out there
trying to predate the Egyptian empire and he says that it's like there's many
empires.
It's not just like one and is it goes back thousands and thousands of years
earlier.
And he has a geologists on his side.
It's really interesting because he's a,
all these different academics are fighting it tooth and nail because it makes
everything had been teaching everybody in school cause it's off by thousands of
years.
They,
they've dated the enclosure of the spanx.
There's these huge like Fisher marks that are in the walls with this,
of this,
the,
this uh,
the stones and what they come from,
every geologist agrees on us is thousands of years of rainfall.
And these are clearly like the way water erodes that aliens built the pyramids.
No,
no.
I think,
I think the Egyptian civilization was most likely as advanced if not more
advanced than we are today,
but in a different direction.
They became advanced with a language like hieroglyphics with incredible
mathematics that we're allowing them to make these geometric structures.
I mean however the fuck they figured out how to do it.
There's a lot of speculation,
but to pretend that the great pyramid of Giza is not an astronomically
incredibly amazing fucking accomplishment is crate.
It's ridiculous.
It's one of the greatest accomplishments of human engineering of all time and no
one even knows when it was Maine.
The gas is 2,500 BC and it's based on like carbon samples and shit they found at
the area,
but it's still,
they're not completely sure about that.
There's a lot of weird speculation and the Sphinx,
the Sphinx with all the,
the,
the deep water erosion around the enclosure.
What they're saying is that that was that.
If that was thousands of years of rainfall than the last time there was heavy
rain fall on the Nile valley was something crazy like 9,000 BC.
So instead of being 2,500 BC like they thought it was,
it was like thousands of you older still.
And we are to them training again.
Crazy it would they,
well,
they used to be a jungle.
It used to be a rain forest Nial valleys to be like a rain forest.
It was raining constantly and then slowly it became a desert.
And the last time there was like heavy rainfall.
It's like 9,000 PC.
It's fucking nuts.
And this area,
this cutout area shows thousands of years of rainfall and the Egyptologist don't
want to address it.
They look at it and it's freaking them out because it's pretty obvious and
there's no getting around it.
If it is rainfall,
the whole thing's got to be thrown out.
And this is the only physical thing they have to show that there was something
that existed that long ago.
And that's why they resist it.
Like the,
the scholars are like,
you know,
where's the evidence of this civilization that it wouldn't have existed 10,000
plus years ago?
There is no evidence.
And you know that what they're saying is,
which this guy's like this shy John Anthony West is saying it's,
there wouldn't really be much.
There's like this stuff.
There's like,
I mean,
10,000 years,
that's an insane amount of time.
10,000 BC.
Come on,
think about how long ago,
12,000 fucking years is think of how crazy that is.
Well,
Christ was only 2007.
Yeah.
Well supposedly,
do you think crash Israel think pressures are real guy?
Yeah.
You think so?
For sure.
Well,
I don't,
I mean,
I don't know why they would make it up.
I'm not saying he's got,
or what about Santa Claus?
Santa Claus for sure.
100%.
Um,
and you know what's amazing about him,
no matter how many people are already takes care of everybody.
If you're good,
if you're good,
you leave a cookie yet,
you know,
it's funny about that.
We're talking about these phrases come down in history.
I was just staying at a hotel in Rochester and they,
for some reason they didn't register my name.
And,
uh,
so the friend of mine finally gets through what she goes,
what are you fucking King Tut?
And I'm thinking,
isn't that interesting that King Tut came down,
he took about Egypt like this kid who was,
who died.
Oh,
that caught with thousands of years ago.
He's still a reference for like a wise ass remark.
You know what I mean?
Yeah,
yeah.
It is pretty ridiculous.
You'll kink fucked and thought in common.
You know,
he had a lopsided head.
Yeah.
The crazy fucked up elongated head.
Who knows that.
But you will,
you ever seen images of what a fan of his attorney,
his family,
there was some weird physical characteristics who family that a lot of the crazy
conspiracy theorists guys really latch onto because it's like,
look at it said he's clearly an alien,
you know,
cause he had like kind of a,
a weird shaped head.
You No,
no.
Normal prose and has a head like that.
What a bad motherfucker he is though.
That we're talking about.
I'm still,
that's what I'm saying.
Yeah.
No.
How old was he when he died?
He was a kid,
right?
Kid.
Yeah.
And I think he was bartered.
Whether I wasn't a murder,
I don't know.
I went to do a bad neighborhood and Cairo,
they probably killed people all day back then.
Oh yeah.
You know,
the idea that John Anthony West is a promoting and set the idea of um,
a lot of these,
uh,
there's a lot of guys that are getting on this,
notions,
possibility of ancient civilizations that were wiped out by disasters.
Once we see shit like the tsunami and you know,
we see things like what Hurricane Katrina can do and we go,
well these,
these aren't even like the biggest storm to the biggest events in history.
What the fuck must have been like with something like this times 10 hit 10,000
years ago,
Mike wipe out most of us,
you know,
and they think that that has probably happened several times to people and that
civilization would reach a great height and then something would happen.
And by the way,
this coincides with two things.
One,
the end of the ice age,
which happened fairly abruptly,
which might've been caused by some sort of an event,
like an asteroid.
And evidence of asteroidal impacts somewhere around that long ago.
Tenting 10,500 plus years ago is the,
uh,
the estimation of when this asteroid hit.
Then you know that they're not completely exact on the date I think,
but they're all similar.
And so there's,
there's,
there's evidence also that we've been pelted in numerous times with asteroids.
Like once they started taking satellite photos,
I would think they would hit us all the time.
You,
all the randomness,
your space.
Well,
they get chewed up by our atmosphere for the most part,
but some of them don't.
Man,
the really big ones don't.
And there's been several extinction events in,
in the lifetime of the earth.
More than three,
and at least two of them that involve giant impacts.
Two of them are just big fucking volcano sized explosion asteroids a five miles
wide slamming into the earth and lava shoots up into the fucking sky and
blankets have Jesus just written a book.
But a lot of that stuff,
right.
Fucking imagine Fred Flinstone wrote books.
Okay.
Could you imagine what it must've been like live in back,
you know,
in the bedrock ears in the,
in the,
in the cave man years when there was like just grunt and shit.
Yeah.
No TV.
Just trying to follow around the herd of Buffalo that no,
you're trying to kill them so they always want to move by night.
So you've got to get up in the middle of the night.
The buffalo are moving and we've got to follow him.
Follow after him.
He baby gets killed by tigers.
Jaguars,
Jack,
your whole fucking family pulling women by the hair.
Do you think they did that?
They clubbed him over the head dragging.
Isn't it funny that that image of the cave men is like the predominant image
Cayman clubbing and check over the head dragging her by her hair.
That's the predominant image of what is a caveman doing.
First of all,
he's always got a club,
right?
Caitlyn's always had clubs and they always had a bear skin.
Some sort of like a Saturday night date,
where the fuck his salary,
why is it but who invented the club over the head and drag her by her hair?
You know,
I don't know.
Maybe it was King Tut,
but bits.
It's an amazing,
I mean,
is it,
isn't it like that?
That's the,
uh,
that's the symbol.
We all say what fuck did that happen?
The club over the head and drag her by the hair.
That,
how many times have you heard that expression,
that expression,
when it comes to cavemen,
it's like super common.
Like what'd you came in?
He's gonna think every girl he meets,
you got clover over their head and dragged by her hair.
Did like looney tunes invent that.
Maybe I wonder,
I wonder who came up with it.
But it stuck culturally,
like all throughout my life.
I remember that the images of club in or girl or they head dragged her by her
hair.
I never knew that they weren't cavemen and dinosaurs together because we always
put them together.
Well,
if you hung out with Sarah Palin,
you would know that that's not factually correct because you,
it's a matter of fact,
there was a school teacher from Alaska that says that Sarah Pailin,
uh,
said that the earth is less than 10,000
years old and that dinosaurs and men did live together.
But mainstream science is trying to keep that from you.
And that there's a images,
there's images on the Internet of a dinosaurs with a human footprint side of it.
I wonder if it's true.
It could be just some hater bitch from Alaska,
you know,
who's the local library and maybe she's a cunt,
and,
and maybe Sarah Pailin blew her husband or something,
you know,
not that she would do that.
Would you do Sarah Palin?
Fuck yeah.
It depends on where I was,
where I was in my life,
where I was.
See he lays back getting may,
maybe it takes him two hours long.
Big.
It's crazy.
He legs glows,
shenanigans ensue.
I'm doing,
I'm Adam Carolla's podcast later.
If you can't get enough of me.
Did you turn it on that and you get that email that said who's coming here?
Uh,
went next Wednesday.
Yeah.
Bobcat Goldthwait fuck.
Well,
don't do that in front of him.
You fuck.
And he wants to forget those days.
And apparently he has an awesome movie.
Yeah,
I know about us moving.
Yeah.
Anthony has was talking all about it on Opie and Anthony.
The name is called God bless America.
You want to see a trailer?
I got a trailer,
but yeah,
I'd love to see a trailer.
I do want to say it.
Pull that shit up.
Yeah.
Bob Cats,
one of those guys that's so mild mannered before he goes on stage.
I think that was,
it goes crazy.
Yeah.
I never knew him as a comic.
So first time I ever met him,
he was a directing the Chappelle show.
And,
uh,
I was,
with Dave,
we were in New York City and Dave was just walking down the street with a fake
mustache on and,
uh,
he was giving out awards for the best New York boobs.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
It was ridiculous.
And this was in the show?
Yeah,
that was the first time I ever met bobcat.
I,
I ran into him on the street.
I'm like,
what are you doing day?
He goes,
Hey Joe Rogan,
you want to help me out?
I go,
I only got like a half an hour.
Oh,
that's cool.
So it's for half an hour.
I carried his box of New York blue ribbons and he would go in and you got some
great New York boobs.
Give people like ribbons chip that's in bobcat was like directing the whole
thing.
So that's the first time I met him.
Very nice guy though.
I always liked him as a comic.
Here's the trailer,
which is our red band trailer,
B.
A.
N.
D.
The most hilarious ringtone ever.
Just tanks pig.
We have a press that just gives them a free pass.
The boys were caught after setting the homeless man on fire.
A tumor.
This size is very dangerous.
You have any family?
Can I take this?
My name is Chloe.
I live in Virginia Beach and everyone loves me because I'm so pretty.
I wanted an escalator.
He creepy isn't a school girl thing.
A little out moving.
Don't make a sound if you want the car.
Just taking my parents got me the wrong one anyways.
Yeah,
that's a fucking tragedy.
Did you just kill flowy?
Awesome.
That was a fantastic start,
but no.
Who else really rips my cock off?
If a Dashi animals,
we use rock stars.
Magic 10 who call their tits?
The girl who was Crystal's.
You're aiming at the bear,
right?
This is the best day ever.
Don't let me
recording this.
Thanks for turning off your cell phone.
You're welcome.
Why have a civilization if we no longer interested in being civilized
it buddy?
What's wrong?
A lot.
A lot of crazy people out there
who want to kill people who deserve to die.
We're going to do this or what?
I know it's not normal to want to kill,
but I am no longer normal.
Whoa.
We got to take both those spots.
Yeah.
Fuck you.
Sounds like
amazing.
Wow.
That's awesome.
That's a scary movie.
That's really cool.
Looks very pop fiction.
Eat kind of again,
like you know,
just bad ass.
You don't kill,
kill,
kill kind of movie.
It looks pretty sweet.
Yeah.
It's obviously got a,
an anti douchebag slant.
Yeah.
Which is always nice.
That's really cool because he,
he's a,
he's a great director.
He did.
When did he do windy city here?
Uh,
no.
Well,
I don't know if he did that,
but he did that clown movie,
which was great.
I saw that in the movie theater.
The city maybe.
Yeah.
That was it.
Was that the one where they faked the guy?
Uh,
dot.
Merera or Don Paris,
isn't it?
It's not embarrassing.
Jay,
Jimmy Kimmel.
It was one of the producers.
That's really funny.
You know,
there's tons of people in that movie.
I've met that dude.
It's just,
it's too tragic.
Uh Huh.
Oh,
someone who's crazy,
who thinks they're actually famous.
Yeah.
We're actually having,
and you got an attitude that's a cracked me up about it.
That's hilarious.
He got an attitude once he made it.
Yeah.
Fake made it.
A few people that don't know what we're talking about.
Dom explained the whole situation because it's really pretty fascinating for
people.
Best I remember is,
uh,
they fabricated this guy becoming a celebrity,
gradually becoming a star.
And he had a movie and it was just,
the whole thing was a mock.
I went him and how else would I,
he thinks it's real.
Like this guy named Perry.
Thanks crazy.
Thanks a,
that he gets a star attitude.
Well,
the peewees,
it's a weird thing.
It's because people aren't paying attention to him and he isn't a movie.
Right?
It's like,
why?
What is that?
Yeah.
So that's why he's so crazy and it's so not,
he's tuned into
a dimension that's like right next door to ours.
You ever met people that are like that?
They're not quite seeing things the way everybody else around us.
A scene.
Right.
You and you to wonder,
what does the world look like to them?
You know,
how many times have you met a comic?
Okay.
He,
perfect example.
Oh,
I know an open mic guys.
They'd come off stage and they fucking eight Dick and they hear phantom laughs.
They'll come off and go,
I'm going to think that one pretty good.
Yeah.
Pretty good set.
I killed.
Yeah.
I've asked people,
you know,
I've asked him while watching them just to silence having silent performances.
Actually a bobcat.
Goldthwait a I definitely uh,
directed a windy city.
He,
here's the Amazon.
Oh,
he directed that as well.
We're having this Friday because we're not having a ice house show Friday we're
having at Wednesday this week we're having the whole Ding Dong show,
having a special podcast here so you can meet them.
And then they're going to talk about their podcast,
which is the big three,
a podcast network.
So we're going to have dawn in the studio,
the big three podcast network.
What does that big three is?
Don Baer says podcast with,
with all the characters from this movie to Paris.
Scary Perry.
And you're going to bring that guy here,
hunt?
Yeah.
When is the Friday at 10 o'clock.
Wow.
You're going to deal with that guy.
Oh,
I'm,
I hang out with all those people all the time.
Did you want that Perry guy like here hanging out?
He's a normal,
he's fine.
He's just crazy.
But he's,
he's not,
he's not going to do anything bad or anything like that.
Plus,
I just upped the insurance and so it'd be a fine,
no,
it's not going to be that,
but it's going to be a descent into madness.
Oh,
that's what the,
if you haven't listened to a podcast,
it's,
it's the most amazing soap opera of a podcast.
It's great.
It's very addicting.
If you're looking for it to get started.
That's been there for a while.
That used to be on Adam Carolla's network,
uh,
and stuff like that.
And then now dawn has a whole studio in his house.
Pretty much has like a studio like this inside his house.
And uh,
it's great.
Neil leads,
you can't be beat that.
The mattress guy that owns that mattress store right here,
a couple of mattresses,
stores big a celebrity in La.
He's now one of the new sponsors and he's now every Ding Dong show.
He comes to the Ding Dong show and he's just crazy
real.
It is insane.
That dude's nuts.
But it's Hilarious,
man.
It's,
if you can say all these characters uncomfortable talking to crazy people,
you,
you don't,
well,
you can have that guy in the studio.
I would be freaking out.
I'd be like,
I can't,
this is not right.
You can't have a conversation while there's someone here that's not having the
same conversation.
Someone here is in another room looking at the whole thing through plexiglass.
Right.
I can,
I can deal with those people in spurts.
Like I'm not going to have the person over to my house or I'm not going to like
fucking start
of those people.
They almost have lego like a consciousness condom on did not feel and everything
that's happening,
it's not during that different reality.
Remember that Guy Joe at late at night on the college to Robert.
I'll do vial or just wrap it up.
I talked to him the other day.
He ran away.
He always liked me.
Me and him always used to get along.
He was a nice guy cause those are like,
like dawn Barris would always be mean to that dude.
And I'm like,
he's not a bad guy man.
He's just kind of crazy.
But he's,
he's a pleasant to be around,
you know?
Yeah.
He's a nice guy.
It's not being mean anybody.
He would walk from downtown.
It was pasta does as a kite,
is he?
Yeah.
No,
not high,
but I don't know.
I smoked weed with that dude.
Have you ever seen his,
uh,
have you ever seen his like his web show that he did with Mary?
I'm Mary Jane and Don produced it.
Uh,
like it's a show for him.
It's kind of like this,
but a podcast.
I'll show you a clip of it.
It will blow your mind.
Go.
Did they start like two years ago they did like Don Barris gone.
Barry's help the help film it and him and Don bears hitting each other.
I'll,
you know,
they all love each other done.
Don takes care of so many people there and you know,
he's Cure Robert William or via,
well he,
you know Mary Jane.
Wow.
That's great practice.
For the longest time I remember he was calling him Hitler and he would always
just see them and put his finger over his nose and say that they're Hitler.
We got to remember Don Paris has been,
they're so fucking long.
Tom Embarrassing there.
From how long would you say?
20 years maybe.
At least always.
Got Along with don bears.
He's a fucking sweetheart of a guy.
I,
I don't think in the 20 years that I've known that guy or how ever long it's
been,
not quite 20 years,
but however many years it's been an la,
never ever had an end even,
uh,
an unpleasant word with dawn Barris.
So sweetheart of a guy relationship story funny cause he,
Eddie Haskell's me.
Good evening,
Mr. Herrera.
How are you doing?
You look great tonight.
It's a beautiful color for you.
It's always like some sort of a uh,
uh,
an act,
you know,
Ho is like put on a certain voice,
fuck around with you.
Him and Brian Cowen have some elaborate rape theme they do every time they see
each other.
Where,
where,
uh,
dawn Barris winds up raping Brian Callan.
It starts out,
I get it always starts out the same way.
It always ends the same way.
There's something about the store where people do stupid shit like that and like
keep it going forever.
Remember the thing they used to have with Eleanor wants to ask her about it.
You got change for a dollar and she would go digging or a prenup start
masturbating and we,
we,
we do this.
This is stupid fucking thing we would do literally once a week for years.
I used to get rubbed together.
She's crazy.
That girl strong to remember when she was a pro wrestler.
I used to go see her easy rider rider,
right.
We,
we went to see her,
she was one of the waitresses and now she's a very funny comic.
Eleanor Kerrigan is her name and she's hilarious and we're so happy she's
finally doing standup because she was always like one of the funniest people
that would hang around at the store and she wasn't even a comic.
She was a waitress.
We had a thing called the punch to the twat where I would go to her.
Ellie I think.
I think so too and I go and I would hit her and I would hit her and she would
act like it hurt and she stagger around it.
She act like she came,
she,
she's really committed to it.
She would start off in like deep,
deep pain and then she would start coming and then she would start coming after
the initial impact of the punch row in a way that like only someone who really
probably enjoys a good twat punch could deliver it.
She mean she embodied that.
He did the idea of it,
but she was a w we would have a long,
I mean we have this,
this thing that was running the comedy store four
fucking years while I'd go,
do you have any,
um,
do you have any change?
Um,
hold on a second.
And she would just start my house,
enter a pinch.
Like
Oh,
and she would like completely commit eyes,
close legs,
pinched together,
toes pigeon fee.
And He'd be like,
I mean,
I only need like a quarter.
If you just have one quarter,
I'll give you a dollar.
No,
no,
no.
Hold on,
hold on,
hold on.
I'm going to get it.
Get it.
And it was so over the top and every time she would do it,
you would try to top it because you know we could,
we're doing the same goddamn gag over and over the years,
you know,
so she would try to try to double it over.
But I remember the can punch.
I remember when you would come Poncho,
and I think you stomped on the ground to pro wrestling style.
Check this out.
John Albert,
Robert William App provide.
That was Robert by the way.
There it goes.
Okay.
He wears that same shirt everywhere.
He goes that same outfit screen and it keeps up.
What does that paper plate that he carries around with that's covered up with
aluminum foil and stuff like that and paper plate covered up with a room and he
keeps it like he protects his head from lasers.
Remember he used to always take like,
like,
like this,
you know,
block his head because he thinks people are shooting lasers at him when he wants
him to the company store.
Yeah.
Whoa.
Jesus Christ.
Lasers.
Yeah.
What is it?
You know,
I wonder if it's,
if he was crazy always or if one day just reality just became too difficult or,
I've never seen them.
Not Crazy,
so I wouldn't,
I mean,
but isn't it weird that there's like two shades of crazy and he's functioning?
He's functioning.
How does he make a living?
I don't know.
No,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Um,
but he does get on stage of the store still goes up.
There's Don Buress is like at a store and Roberts
walking.
Right.
It's funny.
There's a bunch of Paris.
It's so crazy.
It's so awesome.
He's one of those guys that just like I said about your it guys who are around,
you automatically have a smile,
you know,
it add Robert Right here
and was it he,
one of the original guys that was supposed to take over for a Letterman and
that's what he used to always talk about.
What like he was,
there's that,
there's the aluminum.
Yeah.
He was one of the guys.
Was he cool with them doing this and putting this shit online?
Oh,
they're following him around and just filming him.
Dude,
this is probably not the best thing.
I wonder if they had gotten his permission for this.
Is that Charles Fleischer?
Here's a guy,
I haven't seen it forever.
This is for the folks watching at home.
They just following around.
A guy who has a slippery grip on reality,
but a nice enough guy.
Yeah,
he's really,
I always tried to talk to them,
but it sounds it's impossible and how to talk to them.
Like I even tried to give him a joint the other day and he just ran away,
isn't it?
Seeing how the storage is sort of like attracts those types of characters and
Sony,
I mean we've talked about it so many times with that,
that vortex of Hollywood,
that whole area between like the Rainbow Room and the rock Roxy and you know
where the viper room is and all the way down to the store,
his house and even the laugh factory like that area is so strange that such a
vortex of bizarre people for the viper room,
especially if you ever done stand up there.
No,
I haven't.
I've seen a lot of music there and also the rainbows like that eighties.
Yeah.
Tight pants,
rocker.
Look,
they won't let it go.
They,
they found a spot [inaudible] agreed to all go there.
Yeah.
They,
they found a spot where,
you know,
you're going to be able to see someone from that era is going to come buy.
It reminds me of the Kennison days that that place.
Yeah,
right.
He used to talk about it.
It is,
he was a,
his HBO special.
He talks about the rainbow bar and grill,
but meeting crazy girls over there that you uh,
that can't wait to meet you and blame their whole miserable,
fucked up life on you.
He had some great tortured relationship shit.
Uh,
he was funny.
One of the best right when it comes to tortured relationship.
Shit.
I was married for fucking years talking about God meeting the devil.
How it would be like club med,
how old be like club med.
He was a real game changer.
That dude,
it's hard to change the game today.
Everybody's seen everything with the Internet the way it is now.
It's amazing how much more educated people are today and how much more weird
shit information.
Those too.
Yeah,
keep changes.
The,
I did a bit about how there's no place to go and comedy.
I don't know if you're with somebody this base,
like they said,
we've been the sac religious as you can be as vulgar as you can be.
The only thing left to do is actually come on the crowd or the guy at the end of
his act,
his pants up and up and he just started like a fucking machine gun.
People are,
people are running out yet,
but you can't help but turn and look back and you get it right in the Mia.
Imagine easily a culture where it would be okay if the performer came on the
audience.
There's way worse shit out there.
There's way crazier shit out there that people are doing.
I mean you've just,
even,
circumcision is pretty fucking nuts.
Cut and baby decks had been cut and decks for thousands of years.
It's so living.
Remember that show?
No.
Some Sitcom with some chick that was on,
I think she was on celebrity rehab.
One of the first ones
I remember he was George Jetson,
his dog l role.
And what year was the Jetsons supposed to be in the future?
Like 1980 [inaudible].
Isn't it funny that like when you go and look at Shit like that,
they thought was going to be like blade runner appointment.
Do you know when blade runner was supposed to be taking place in 2019 Oh really?
Yeah.
What is this?
It's a living.
I don't remember this at all.
Wow.
Look at all these fake,
Ooh,
she's Melfi
where all these women now don't,
don't even bring it up,
but she's high level.
She's still hot.
It's got a lot of Melfi Shit gone.
That's Melfi
hope she works out.
She's printing somebody put a Photoshop together with where all these girls look
like now
and Jillian,
I know her.
I did.
And did a roast would Mike did gives you his own,
is that guy a comic?
I Dunno.
Sweared sitcoms.
Wacky chef.
I've never seen the show before me crazy.
Just go with Thomas.
What
time?
What year was that?
But Standing Thomas' son?
Yeah.
What year was that?
That it's a living was on the air show.
I never saw that show.
I don't know why I remember that.
Not only that,
you remember the theme 19 1980s is always 1980s wow.
I remember that show was,
I think I was in high school.
It was on the air.
He's amazing how much culture has evolved from that to,
uh,
what's Larry David's show?
Caribbean,
Caribbean.
Tuesday.
You think of that?
Think of the difference between that show how complex and hilarious and
brilliant and multilayered and facet is where it just gets twisted up into
things.
We're,
you know,
I mean he went,
remember when they had a water bottle in his pants and the girl came in the
bathroom.
I mean,
he's just,
he's unbelievable.
Unbelievable.
Just to say that a friend of mine worked for both the,
everybody loves Raymond and Seinfeld and he said to me,
Raymond was so simple cause it was in a plot.
The whole show is,
and they plot sometimes a B Seinfeld was ABCD and they throw everything.
Oh yeah,
we hit the golf ball.
It goes into the wheels.
Blowhole and Jason Alexander Lives about being a marine biologist,
biologist,
everything for the way everything fit together in 22 minutes clean and they had
to work clean.
Yeah,
it wasn't brilliant.
Brilliant show and you know,
if you look at like those old father knows best and it's almost like a different
species of thing,
like people were so stupid.
How could you have this show on the air who the w you realize how naive culture
was just Justin.
The only one that holds up holds up to me and makes me live stills Andy of
Mayberry,
which just listen to what you said about the twilight's on that holds up.
That's true.
I love that they wake up and they realized they were actually getting further
away from the son.
Jesus Christ.
Creepy,
creepy fucking challenge.
Twilight zone was amazing.
Remember to serve man.
Yes,
the aliens came.
It was a cookbook.
Cookbook.
It's a cookbook.
Well,
if you think about the way we treat dolphins and the way we treat killer whales,
I would think that if aliens came here,
they might either fuck us or eat us.
It's very possible.
Right.
If they were way smarter than us,
if we're,
if they look at us,
we're so stupid,
we're still using nuclear power and he assholes or pollute and everything.
You know,
he give a fuck and they Adidas.
That's why I have a poor diet diet.
I don't want to be delicious to those.
Well,
you really think about it,
you'd die.
It probably makes you delicious.
Yeah.
Like a Wagyu steak.
Like when they get that Coby beef.
Yeah.
I mean they feed it liquor and they massage it and it's perfect.
It's just like,
hey,
that's a day in the life on the road.
Get a nice deep tissue before the show loosen up.
He might,
if I drank while you're rubbing my back.
Yeah.
Do you ever get,
um,
a deep tissue massage?
No,
I don't.
I don't,
I'm not a big massage guy.
Really?
Not even at the rub and tug kind of massages I used to,
but I don't have any fetishes.
Those are hard to find.
Right.
Um,
fetishes make me a dress up in diapers or do anything weird like that?
No,
you're done in papers.
Brian pick the funniest fetish ever heard,
I don't know if it's true,
was Elton John.
He liked to run across the room naked and people guys would throw oranges.
Adam at Isaiah,
that was his thing that supposedly,
but that's like Rod Stewart supposedly had to get a stomach pump cause there was
like a court and a half ago he blew his soccer team
in lieu of pay.
I'd like to blow all of you the best rumor of all time though.
The king in the rumors.
There's the Richard Gere dribble up the ass Romer.
That's the Mike Tyson of 1985 I never had a dribble up my,
I think Scientology might've done it to him.
I think he had been involved.
Could think they really put a dribble and said no.
They probably spread the rumor that room or get,
you know Eddie Bravo grew up here in la.
I grew up in Boston and we both heard that rumor paper,
the whole country.
Joe,
who's the first guy that thought I'm going to put an animal in ways.
I think people are nuts.
They put all kinds of things in their ass.
I mean an animal alive.
There's always someone looking at tickets to the next level.
They found a guy,
he was drunk driving.
He had a zebra and his car,
a zebra and giraffe or some shit like that.
I just tweeted.
Yeah.
You think you've seen everything you think well,
I've pretty much figured out like what people are capable of and what they're
not.
Oh No,
no,
no.
Let me,
let me read this too because it is the most ridiculous shit
we had.
Ana,
same triple,
he's nicer.
Last night,
a woman that was bonded to mistress and she has her own personal slave and it
was so weird,
was like Paul fixing where like bring out the Gump and his girl just add like a
month at a time,
which is live with this woman and her boyfriend who was the guy from no FX.
People are so crazy.
They just were like,
all right,
you went in to see us beat her and so she like,
like here,
they're just,
she's like wailing on this girl with these whips and stuff.
By the way,
the guy had a zebra and a parrot in the front seat of his truck and he got
arrested in Dubuque.
I was driving drunk with a zebra and a parrot.
I don't,
I don't know.
How can he fly
brew?
I don't understand it.
I'm looking at it here.
It's a little zebra.
Obviously.
It's not a big zero.
It was a fucking zebra.
Whoa.
This assholes driving around with a Z,
but like it says Jack Russell terrier.
Hey,
you guys want to go for a ride on a train to Zebra?
Isn't it amazing that you could just,
this sound me.
I was like zebras.
You could just buy.
You just figured out a way to buy it.
How the fuck can you just buy a zebra man?
Craigslist,
you can buy,
you can buy a fucking tank.
Used to.
Wow.
They have a little zebra man.
I'm looking at this man arrested for Owi with Zebra Parrot in front seat of
truck.
Just Google that and then there's a video and he's got a parrot or a lady has a
parrot sitting on her shoulder and there's a guy,
he's,
he's just a fucking crazy old cracker and the as a pet.
Oh Wow.
Look at this.
We're going to just find while looking at this was a breeder of miniature
donkeys.
Giant grant.
Zebra.
Yeah.
Lot and you could buy.
I see what's for sale right now.
Oh my God.
Z Zebra fucking byesie Bro.
Dude,
dude,
look at it.
How about a z donkey?
The donkey.
Look at that.
Look at that thing.
Scroll up.
That's half.
Zebra has donkey son.
Is He dark?
It is.
Oh my God.
I was joking around.
That's what it's called.
A Z Dong a jasmine as these donk.
When I said z donkey,
I was joking,
dude,
that's you need to get as a donkey.
Just a half donkey have zebra.
That's insane.
Giant Zebra.
$5,000 do you have your own zebra for 5,000 fuck.
When I do with a zero look,
look at the Z.
I want to watch a video
doggy.
I wonder if the zebra fuck the donkey or the donkey.
Fuck the zebra.
Zebra did the fucking,
they get this little apple Jack.
I think your readers are wild.
Fuck is that.
We're looking at something that says a spotted miniature donkey Jack.
Oh my God.
I gotta get Outta here.
I gotta go dude.
I got to be an Adam Carolla's place in half an hour.
The End Dahmer area.
The fucking king as always.
Always Fun,
man.
Thank you.
It couldn't have been more fun.
Anytime you want to do it again.
We keep doing it.
We do it constantly.
I love will never stop down.
My rarer,
you are officially in the desk squad now.
You comfortable with that comfortable test squad [inaudible] right?
Can we agree?
We'll have a meeting.
We'll,
we'll,
we'll cut
Tropicana.
If I can.
Boom,
please.
June 30th go see the great don,
my rare,
one of the funniest comics of all time.
And then it's not eat.
That's even in comedy central comedy central.
He even says that was 79 fucking savage than,
and he was 78 and suck it suck at Bobby.
Uh,
thank you to the fleshlight for sponsoring our podcast.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link for the flashlight.
Enter in the code name Brogan and save yourself some money.
So I'm 15% off.
How about that?
Thanks.
Also to onnit.com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha Brain shroom tech sport,
which I take before I work out,
which keeps me so yoked.
Shroom tech immune pumps up your immune system and new mood,
which has a five HTP,
so it's all explained on a.com.
It's fabulous.
It's wonderful.
And we got kettlebells coming out very soon.
O n n I t.com.
Talk to you it soon.
Oh,
next.
Uh,
w what do we got tomorrow?
we have Joey Coco Diaz.
Yes,
Joey Diaz is tomorrow at one o'clock I believe.
Then we got Bert Kreischer.
What times we crash?
Dirt broke crushes on
Thursday.
Okay,
cool.
Thanks.
Wait,
there's that one.
I said I didn't know about burgers.
I got it.
I'm,
I,
I shouldn't be taking care of this.
I'm too fucking brain to be,
uh,
I,
I made a um,
a tweet about it.
Let me read my tweet,
my own tweets all know who's on a podcast this week.
I want to get one of these little zebra cherry dark.
You don't want to have a fuckin zebra wanting to run your household.
What about this little horse thing?
What was it called again?
A Cherry or dark dark Chrysler's on Thursday.
Yes.
I just wanted to confirm because it wasn't,
because I know there was,
we tried to do another day but he couldn't make it.
And then,
uh,
next week we've got Shane Smith coming up.
Bassnectar we got a,
a lot of shit coming up.
Cat Bobcat Goldthwait next Wednesday.
So next Wednesday we got a,
that's a hot three right there,
ladies and gentlemen.
Bassnectar come on son.
We're going to have a good time and Shane Smith will return and tell us some
more fucking crazy stories about wherever that guy's been,
all over the world.
Sweet.
She got to get my Anthony Bourdain on the show and talk about olive garden,
so all garden sucks.
You got to shut it up.
He's going to stab you.
Anthony Bordain is gonna stab you.
I'll see you guys tomorrow.
All right.
Uh,
early.
It'll be one o'clock for Joey Diaz later.
Bye.
Great.